hearing on House Bill 1333 and called
Day good morning Madam chair and the
rest of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Mark PR I represent Hillsboro 15 which
is Manchester Ward 8 I feel like I'm
back in the committee I've been here so
often but that's okay nice to see
friendly faces so I'm bringing uh this
bill forward to prevent the state from
using electric vehicles for 10 years
because I don't believe that technology
is where it needs to be and it'll end up
costing the state more
money uh my first concern as a
firefighter wrer um I've been reading
about it seeing it haven't really
experienced firsthand but Town Two Towns
over had had one um the safety hazard is
fire uh the batteries tend to run away
fairly easy and it's called a thermal
runaway and they just kind of ignite
burn twice as hot as a regular
carire
uh the bad part of that is soon as that
happens the electrical system in the car
shuts down and the doors are electric
you cannot get out and now due to
Federal mandates all the windows are
laminate so you can't just hit them with
a hammer and they crumble like they used
to you have to actually rip the windows
out or cut them with a
saw um so it makes it harder to get out
uh we have noticed that in a lot of
these carf fires you find all the
occupants in the back seat trying to get
away from the smoke and the fire the
other thing that happens when these
batteries run away they create toxic
fumes that kill you before the smoke
would so you can't get out you
trapped and for us on the fire side what
used to take us less than a th000
gallons to put out a carire now it takes
us 30 to 40,000 gallons to manage these
and I say manage cuz we really can't put
them out for a long period we're cooling
it down so the thermal stops we have to
cool it for an hour wait 45 minutes to
see if it starts then if you can get a
tow truck to actually take it the
firetruck has to follow the tow truck in
case it starts again in their lot they
have to keep them separate
right that's the safety
thing now we get into the batteries
right with with these big batteries the
weight of the car is twice of what the
uh regular vehicle would
be um I have another build that
addresses some of
that but replacement is pretty expensive
I was uh just watching a report
um that Hyundai a person was driving ran
over a muffler that fell off dented the
battery bad enough that it was damaged
first of all noal local shop will touch
it the autobodies won't touch it it has
to go back to the dealer the price to
$61,000 because they don't keep them in
stock they weigh so much and they have
to come for the Hyundai they have to
come from
Korea and for the battery it was
61,000 I got to think that's got to be
the almost the price of the car but and
that's what happens the batteries
eventually wear out up here in New
England cold affects any battery
shortens the life of that charge so you
used to be able to get 300 if it's
really cold that day you may get 150
miles right so there's definitely
problems with these um finding charging
stations for
them and
then when that battery does wear out
three four five years are you going to
replace it or are you going to get rid
of the car I know and this is a little
bit of an older story that in Paris when
they kind of first all came out they
went all electric the battery started
wearing out on these cars they went to
replace them and found out that it was
very expensive to do so they said well
we don't want to do that we'll just buy
new ones and get rid of these cars
nobody wanted them because the battery
is a hazardous
material so they had a big field that
the city owned and now there are cars
sitting there rotting away because
there's no place else to get rid of them
so I see at this time uh the other piece
is the material raw materials for the
batteries a lot of it comes from
countries that really don't like
us and at any time they could would say
yeah we're not sending you anymore or
not building you any more batteries and
now we're kind of stuck with all these
cars or this technology that we're
moving to that you can't continue so I
just see that there's a lot of problems
with it I see that it's going to cost
State payers more money in the long run
at least that's what I believe um and
with that I'll end my testimony and take
questions thank you representative are
there questions
representative
Schmid now why don't you tell us how you
really
feel you don't want representative
Schmid that was that was just a that was
disrespectful representative Pro and I
are long time long time friends he
wouldn't believe it was me if I didn't
correct so uh thank you for this very
interesting
presentation and I'm wondering why why
do you think that the state would even
possibly be interested you you can't be
the only one that knows the problems
there's a request for bid for electric
state thank you that's interesting to
know okay anyone
else representative Brown good morning
thank you madam chair uh thanks for
taking my question do you have a an idea
of how many EV car fires we're seeing in
New
Hampshire I don't have an exact number
but I know they're on the increase and I
can tell you other carire stories if you
want but I figured I wouldn't waste your
time with it there are some and
and they are twice as hot twice as fast
and sometimes they
catastrophic they'll
detonate black thank you so you talked
about some departments you know Public
Safety out uh departments uh buying
these things are they buying cars or
they're actually trying to buy trucks
or
so they're electric there are electric
fire trucks and I can't believe that
there are uh so but it's a dual power
system right so the battery drives the
truck to the fire but they use a diesel
engine to drive the pump because we know
the battery would not last long enough
at a big fire and how can you charge it
when you're at a fire you can bring
diesel to it but you can't bring the big
extension cord right thank you okay
Representative Patrick thank you madam
chair uh through my own research as a
consumer I I I can certainly verify
everything that you've said uh have you
taken into consideration
hybrids there still that
battery well the hybrids oh I'm not
going to get into an argument thank you
thank you madam chair thank
you representative uh thank
you well following on from what he asked
are there some brands or types that are
better than others or they all have the
same problem they all have the same
problem they're all the same
technology give or take maybe a little a
little bit but the battery itself is all
the same
technology
uh they all can have that uh ability to
Thermal runaway and and from
hoverboards the automobiles same
technology we've seen the
hoverboards uh detonate in a house while
it's charging right and uh they have the
electric bike
well they don't want to bring them in
into the house so they charge them in
the hallway of the apartment building
and now they have a fire in the hallway
and nobody can get out those are some of
the things but we're not talking about
those but the technology is the same the
batteries are the same and they all act
the same way thank you
okay thank you very much thank you
representative
Hobson
thank you madam chair and honorable
colleagues my name is Deb Hobson I'm
state representative for Rockingham
district 14 I here today to support
hb33
um prohibiting state agencies from
buying or leasing Fleet electric
vehicles for 10 years the extremely cold
temperatures in New Hampshire and across
the country last week gave proof that
the elect elect car industry though well
intentioned is not ready to become
mainstream or required for quite some
time these electric vehicles lose
mileage range in the cold weather and
the batteries don't react well to
fluctuating
temperatures they don't hold their Char
they don't hold their charge and their
mile mileage range is cut by 30 to
40% insurance rates are higher for EVS
according to a AAA report they're more
more prone to damage in an accident and
more costly to repair I was privileged
to attend a higher uh sorry lost my
place I was privileged to attend a
training seminar for SE Coast fire
chiefs with four to 500 other First
Responders in late summer last year I
was shocked to hear some of the concerns
brought to light from this training here
are some here are just a few electric
vehicles immediately shut down when the
electrical system is compromised and the
occupant is unable to leave the vehicle
unless they know where the release is
for that vehicle and it's different in
every electric brand the fire
temperature starts at 2800° and the fire
size doubles every 15 seconds the smoke
from an EV fire is not smoke it's toxic
gas consisting of hydrogen volatile
organic chemicals CO2 and methane which
is toxic to vehicle operators and First
Responders there is currently no fire
fighting protocol to fight these fires
the fires burn until they burn out and
when deprived of ox oxygen they reignite
when oxygen hits them as long as a month
later these temperatures are so hot that
First Responders can't get near the fire
as their gear is rated for just 800 de
degrees thermal runaway which
representative PR talked about it's a
chain of events that typically starts
with the gradual breakdown of EV battery
cells causing preheating of the EV cells
and battery pack the elevated
temperatures within the EV battery
causes the organic solvents to break
down resulting in the release of gas
increased pressure and temperatures
Beyond flash point so it pops and it
spreads to all the
um all the um materials around it fires
and EV batteries are triggered by
thermal runaway as a known safety hazard
in all lithium ion batteries can be
caused by short circuiting mechanical
stress to the EV battery from Impact
during an accident overheating poor
Cooling in temperatures condensation and
moisture in the EV pack and a
manufacturing defect this is all cited
by Honeywell most protocols now indicate
to let the fire burn itself out or to D
with large amounts of water anywhere
from 5 to 25,000 gallons requiring more
manpower hours which leaves Area fire
stations underst staffed while
supervising these fires these V vehicles
are burdensome and dangerous not just to
the drivers but to the environment as
well these problems needs to need to be
worked out before they can become
mainstream Solutions please vote this
measure ought to pass to allow for the
industry to fix these problems without
endangering the environment or lives of
drivers to prevent unnecessary Death
thank
you any questions thank you very much
representative
Bernardi
thank you madam chair and committee uh
representative JD bernardy Rockingham 36
Hampton Falls uh Kensington Southampton
Newton and plastow uh the bottom line
here is EVS are not ready for prime time
uh you heard some of the reasons already
cold happens yes cold does happen in New
Hampshire it minimizes
range and maximizes charging time but uh
I just I did a little search even last
night on uh news articles with problems
associated with EVS uh first one that
popped up Asheville North Carolina Fleet
is not performing well in cold winter
months uh the range has been dropped to
78 miles for their vehicles equivalent
to three trips to their airport before
they could be charged for several
hours just last just uh in earlier uh
last month in December Maine forced to
delay vote on EV mandate amid widespread
power
outages Governor Janet Mills declares
state of civil emergency for 14 main
counties following a significant wind
and rainstorm that left hundreds of
thousands of people without power and
that cause significant flooding and
infrastructure damage including town and
state
roadways now I want to point out that I
said rain not snow it's even worse when
snow representative golden noted that
that week the storm strong would render
electric vehicles useless giving the
need for Reliable electric generation
uh given their need for Reliable El
supplies the same article noted that
Connecticut has abandoned its EV mandate
because of various Associated
problems uh you saw I think if you have
a phone wonderful little memes and
pictures of what happened in Chicago uh
last week with with the uh with the
storm there that left all the Teslas at
the charging station and no charging
happened and then having to be towed to
the
dealership Herz just announced rental
giant Herz dumps EVS including Teslas
for gas
cars rental firm Hertz Global Holdings
selling about 20,000 EVS including
Teslas from a US Fleet about uh 2 years
years old after uh a deal with the
automaker to offer the vehicles for rent
in another sign that EV mandate has
cooled what's the reason citing
collision and damage for EVS the costs
of those uh are much higher than they
had
expected
so that's what's going on particularly
around the the northern states um and I
want to add another uh area of
problems EVS require further building
out of our infrastructure and you have
heard I think many times that uh New
Hampshire is is Teeters on the edge of
blackouts in the winter when we have
severe winter storms because winter is
one of our electric demand Peaks we also
have a a demand peak in the summer but
what we're doing when we add EVS to the
system is we're adding a larger
requirement for electricity to the grid
and that requires building out of more
trans uh transmission and distribution
lines more Transformers and all those
costs are paid by all of us as rate
payers not the buyers of the EVS but all
of us are going to see our electric
rates go up further because we need more
Transportation more excuse me more
distribution
lines you heard two of the other
speakers discuss the issue of weight a
typical EV is about
150% of the weight of a of a regular gas
driven car that adds more wear and tear
to our to our roads and they're not
paying the gas
tax and I'm not going to go over the
safety issues which were well documented
by representative Hobson and PR uh so
I'll take any questions at this time
thank you are
questions
you John
Gage mam chair yes if I could just ask
the people who are testifying seem to
have prepared documents I'm wondering
whether they can hand some of those in
for the clerk that would be
please thank you chairwoman uh committee
members
um you may remember me from last week
asking for um a bill that would require
the state procurement of transportation
and building heating equipment to use
proxy carbon pricing um which will tilt
the decision making process in favor of
EVs and heat pumps um 10 years is a long
time as far as technology goes do you
remember what your cell phone looked
like 10 years ago um we we don't know
what EES are going to look like 10 years
from now even three years from now
I came here in an EV I bought it about a
month and a half ago uh it works fine in
snow it's allel drive it has a little
high clearance it's AIA
ev6 um in warm weather 100 280 mil range
in cold weather I lose about 20% of that
um and that's because heat takes a lot
of energy if I don't mind being cold I
get better range than that um what the
state is lacking is infrastructure for
my car um um I drove 200 miles round
trip to the White Mountains to do a hike
a couple weeks ago and I made it back
with 40 mil range left but that's not a
good feeling knowing that there's no
superchargers north of conquered that I
can use so rather than the state using
um a mandate not to use EVS I'd like the
state to look forward to the the people
that are coming from out of state in EVs
and and how can we best support them
coming here so that they don't have
range anxiety thinking New Hampshire is
a a dark spot on the map that they dare
not
go
um all costs are paid by the public uh
representative Bernardi claimed um
there's enormous external costs in our
using fossil fuels that we are all
paying for much more than a slight
increase in rates um that could pay for
just deploying a good EV charging
infrastructure so in conclusion I just
hope you will I oppose this bill and I
hope you will vote it down um looking
forward to what how the state can save
money uh EVS are cheaper per mile in
total cost of ownership now and they're
just going to keep getting better um so
please look ahead and plan on electric
future for our state um Don't Look Back
to the last century and think that we're
going to really succeed if we go back um
and keep trying to do the same things
much thank you are there questions
represent
Manti thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question
um from your perspective you the
technology changes what is the
typical period in which the technology
advances happen period of 6 months a
year two years what is
your understanding of Technology thanks
I worked in technology for 40 years at
Sun Microsystems and an Oracle
corporation uh it's hard to predict
where the advances are going to come
other than advances are going to come
but I've read recently Toyota is working
on a battery that has 750 miles range
it's I think solid state charges really
fast um that's going to be here in a
couple years right um we we should not
do mandates to prevent ourselves from
preparing for the future that's a bad
idea and most of you don't want mandate
so I I would be surprised if you voted
for a mandate against looking ahead uh
to save the state money um yeah what
what is electric vehicle options going
to be like well five years ago there
were very few options if you wanted an
EV and you need to get somewhere you b a
Tesla now there's you know a dozen major
Mar manufacturers with many models
available um and I love my EV it's
really a cool car it's it's quiet
comfortable um and you feel good because
you're polluting a lot less um and you
just want charging infrastructure so
that you have no worry about where to go
charge and I think the state um if it
was using electric vehicles it would be
motivated to help make that happen Okay
representative
Smith thank you Madam chair uh good
morning uh what are they doing okay so
they're getting more charging stations
that's good however what are they doing
about the batteries themselves are they
improving are they working on that so
that they don't catch fire what are they
doing for the glass around the windows
are they making it less or more
breakable so that in an accident you can
get out or you can also breathe some
fresh air what are they doing along
those lines
yeah there's mechanical ways I mean
breaking glass uh there's a a device
police have that you just has a really
sharp point that will work on a car
window anymore but it doesn't work yeah
what are they doing to improve it
otherwise you're in a box and you're
stuck there with that Co that gas coming
at you um you know that you got to
protect the people driving you do but
we're not stopping everybody from buying
EVS there there are a lot of EVS on the
road and there a lot of EVS coming into
State um New Hampshire is not going to
prevent EV deployment um this is a a
rapidly growing solution to replace
fossil fuel powered vehicles um we need
to train our police and fire on the
different ways of handling EVS versus
combustion engines but just as they had
to understand how to manage a gasoline
Leak with stuff spread all over the
ground that that's not safe um there's
different ways of being safe with an EV
and we should know both of them because
we have drivers in the state with both
Technologies but 10 years would give a
chance for more uh research and trial
and error than what we have right now
that's all okay thank you for answering
was that a question thank you
no representative
Brown thank you madam chair uh thank you
Mr Gage for taking my question G to kind
of follow up on what I asked you last
week um that Madame chair helped me
understand a little bit so I want to be
clear from you when you
say it's a feel-good that you're not
polluting as much and we had the
conversation last week that CO2 hasn't
been classified as a pollutant
so and let's set aside the battery life
cycle and development what do you see as
you're saving it um
as when you say you're driving an EV to
be less polluting can you tell me what
you mean by that yeah sure well I'm
saving money first of all the total cost
of ownership of a car miles driven it's
less than an EV and you know I got mine
Green Wave EV uh one-year-old model so I
saved some money that way U but as far
as um carbon dioxide being a pollutant
um we have a state climate scientist Dr
Mary stampone of University of New
Hampshire and she is far more qualified
than I am to explain to you what we are
doing at a from a expert level I've read
a lot of reports from uh the United
States Global change research program
the international government um panel on
climate change and out of the 200
scientific organizations that I know
about none of them dispute the
scientific consensus that carbon dioxide
from burning fossil fuels is changing
the physical and chemical nature of our
air land and water in ways that cost us
greatly um I think the EPA did rule that
CO2 is pollution um the a more recent
ruling okay thank
you thank you for your
Fitzgerald
morning Madam chair and members of the
committee my name is Mike Fitzgerald um
I am the assistant director of the air
Resources Division at the Department of
Environmental Services uh we take no
particular position on this bill um
there are numerous bills related to
electric vehicles as a matter of fact
you have another one come being heard
this morning um what I just wanted to
bring to your attention is that there
are currently uh two bills that would
create study commissions uh one in the
house and one in the Senate s sp430 and
HB
1510 these two uh uh commissions would
uh propose to study uh barriers to
electric vehicle entry into the markets
and also uh issues such as these fires
and so on last week at the Senate Bill
430 uh uh study commission Bill hearing
the State Fire Marshall was asked about
the number of fires and his indication
at that time was that to the best of his
knowledge and the data that he had
access to here in the state that um
we've had two EV fires um the uh uh we
have approximately 10 um at least 12,000
EVS currently operating on the the uh
uh cities and streets of U of New
Hampshire so um but again uh the these
two commissions would uh uh we think
would be good uh Vehicles no pun
intended for uh uh the uh study of some
of the issues that have been raised here
um we do think and the fire marshal uh I
know agrees that um there there are some
safety issues and they need they need to
be looked at proper training as was
mentioned by Mr Gage um so on uh you
know the these these when we need to
look at the real data um get the
information and uh and and then make
decisions and both of these committees
would proposed to do that so um we would
suggest that the committee at least
consider um uh holding these bills for
interim study until these Comm whether
there's a decision made to to create
these commissions and uh um and allow
them to do some some work getting uh
good accurate information and providing
that to the legislature and making any
recommendations for legislation we do
convene at Dees in or a group of state
agencies that have uh interests in uh
electric vehicles this is a tourism
issue as well State of New Hampshire uh
as was noted does have um a lack of
infrastructure for electric vehicles um
we we administer the Volkswagen
mitigation trust that um was created
several years years ago that supplies
$30 million to the state of New
Hampshire to um mitigate the the issues
associated with the Volkswagen cheating
scandal and um the governor did allow uh
us and and directed us to uh uh set
aside the maximum of 15% of that uh $30
million to uh use for um electric
vehicle infrastructure Etc noting that
you know we need we needed to do this um
several agencies are involved in in um
this group that we facilitate and there
are a number of agencies that are
promoting and I know some are here today
um to uh uh to possibly to discuss their
efforts in in getting additional EV
infrastructure here in the state um if
you look at a map of EV charging in New
England um where the hole in the donnut
there's there's a lot of uh EV charging
in uh all the states around us um and
we're trying to to uh uh to work to
catch up on that so um with that I'd be
happy to take uh questions I also have
with me today Jessica Wilcox who's in
charge of our motor uh vehicle emissions
programs and uh our efforts and the VW
trust um so if you have questions about
any of that um I might ask her to join
me and and uh provide some information
but I'll do the best I can if if there
there are questions thank you for your
attention I would like you to repeat the
numbers of those two bills SB
430 and HB 1510
1510 yes thank you very much are there
any questions representative Benjy thank
you madam chair um thank you for taking
my question um you talked about uh two
vehicles EV Vehicles catching on fire do
you have any statistics for
um gas vehicle the number of on the road
um
and representative manuti he reported
that as secondhand from the fire
marshal so he may not have that in May
well not have that information available
can I ask a different question please
thank you so how are our neighboring
states addressing the safety with the
eveve you mentioned this is a donnut ho
New Hampshire is a donut hold well my my
reference there was in terms of EV
infrastructure charging infrastructure
um uh I I know the Fire Marshall has
been in touch with uh a number of his uh
uh cohorts in in in other states
relative to the safety issues um I can't
again I would not want to testify on his
behalf I just wanted to mention that
anecdotally that um because the question
was asked um and uh I I would certainly
recommend that um you reach out I I will
speak to him and and let him know but uh
uh what the other states are doing I'm
I'm unaware of any other states
proposing uh moratoriums um at least in
in the Northeast but um I certainly
would not you know I'd want to research
that and get back to you on
it thank you other
questions thank you very much thank
Rodriguez
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee for the record my name is
David Rodriguez please speak in the
microphone thank you sorry about that
good morning for the record my name is
David rodrig I'm the assistant
commissioner and chief engineer for New
Hampshire Department of
Transportation thank you for hearing my
testimony on HB 1333
the department does not support or
oppose a bill however we do have some
concerns and a suggestion the department
understands that like many new
technologies there are challenges and
complexities with the growth of electric
vehicles not the least of which include
cost of the vehicles cost construction
and maintenance of charging
infrastructure for the individual for
the public and for for vehicle fleets
limitations to our electricity Supply
and distribution limitations to
electrical switches Transformers and
other electrical equipment safety
related to battery fires on the road and
inst structures first responder
knowledge and safety and responding to
battery fires Towing and storing of
damaged vehicles and batteries repair
Andor disposal of electric vehicles in
funding of the planning design
construction operations and maintenance
of the transportation systems for
vehicles that do not contribute to the
road toll or fuel tax the department
also understands that while these
challenges and complexities are
difficult and real they will be worked
out in time as the technology develops
from a DOT Fleet perspective the
department Fleet includes over 1,250
pieces at a replacement cost exceeding
$120 million the we contains 71
passenger Autos 146 light duty trucks
SUVs and vans and 163 3/4 ton trucks the
department currently owns zero electric
vehicles as we consider adding electric
vehicles to our Fleet our number one
concern is what job function can use the
vehicle efficiently and effectively and
how will we charge the vehicle we next
consider short-term long-term cost
maintenance and function to date our
analysis has not identified an efficient
effective electric vehicle for our Fleet
range cold weather performance cost the
ability to reassign the vehicle to other
functions in the department charging
infrastructure as well as maintenance
technician training and tooling have
prevented us from finding a positive
cost benefit ratio that would lead to
our purchase of electric vehicles
however the department includes many
professionals committed to providing the
best transportation system at the best
cost for the citizens of New Hampshire
and our visitors we need many different
skilled people Technologies equipment
tools and material to do that work we
analyze the complexities of every
decision point when it comes to
providing this system and we follow the
laws of our state even those laws that
do not lead us to the best trans
transportation system at the best cost
while we have zero electric vehicles
today we are concerned that a law which
prohibits us from purchasing or leasing
any electric vehicles for 10 years May
in the end Force us to make Fleet
decisions that do not lead to the best
transportation system at the best cost
for our citizens the department would
like to highlight the final report of
the electric vehicle charging state
ations infrastructure commission
established under SP 517 in 2018 the
commission suggested using the
transportation Council that's
established under RSA 238 A2 as a body
best suited to continue their work the
department suggests that this bill and
others addressing the complex issues
coming from electric vehicles be
referred to the transportation Council
for investigation with recommendations
coming back to the general court the New
Hampshire Transportation Council was
established by the legislature to look
at new
Transportation Technologies and modes
such as electric vehicles given the
number of EV related bills filed a
session and the related various complex
issue the council is a good resource for
the legisl to use to look at those bills
thank you for hearing my testimony and
I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you we would like to have a copy
of your uh your testimony thank you that
would be helpful representative leus
thank you um seem to imply that there
might be existing statutes that prevent
the department from buying what would be
the best vehicles for the state if there
are such could you please send a list of
those to the
committee sure basically they are our
procurement standards which require us
to to do low bid and make it very
difficult for us to do a best life life
cycle cost uh analysis in the overhead
that's that's required to go through
those processes okay thank you okay
thank you other questions representative
Schmidt I I'm sure you're thinking in
the same direction that several of us
are that uh some of the issues
especially that the commissioner is uh
raising suggest that uh this may need to
go to subcommittee have you decided that
yet no but I know that if it does it
will go to the representative Shu
subcommittee thank
you okay other
Fredericks
good morning and thank you uh my name is
m friedricks um and I am with 350 New
Hampshire action but I am also an
elected official in Durham and I will
speak mainly um from my experience there
um there are a number of issues in this
bill um that raised a lot of concern in
terms of its um preparedness for being
considered um one is that um when we
look at line five includes um any hybrid
vehicles hybrid vehicles do not connect
to the electric grid uh plug-in hybrid
vehicles do hybrid vehicles are a
technology that have been around since
the early 2000s um in fact the car I
drove in this morning is a 2007 Hybrid
uh it does not connect to the electric
grid um and the concern from a a a town
standpoint extends to really what it
means to be a taxpayer in this state so
um the town of Durham has been using
hybrid vehicles within its Town Fleet um
for more than 10 years at this point um
the cost savings have been so
significant that we have managed to um
expand considerably the number of town
vehicles and how frequently we are able
to replace those Vehicles while keeping
the town budget flat um and the tax rate
flat for the last seven or eight years I
don't know how many towns in New
Hampshire can say the same thing so
there have been significant cost savings
to the town by adopting um you know
adopting um hybrid vehicles and we are
now starting to incorporate electric
vehicles into the town Fleet for the
same reason um we obviously vet that
through our fire department first and
there are occasions where it's been
determined that it's not appropriate um
because the technology isn't there yet
um but the State Fire Marshall has
testified that EVs do not represent um
are are not more likely to catch fire um
I myself have seen data suggesting that
um that uh EVS are actually less likely
to catch fire than traditional internal
combus combustion vehicles um so I I
hope that the committee would look into
that research further um of course EV as
um they do burn hotter um and so there
are some concerns about whether that
would take fire departments who are
unprepared or untrained longer to put
out those fires but that's where I think
that proper training is up utmost
important um we had do that throughout
you know our history as a state as the
state Incorporated new technologies when
we added natural gas systems when we
started using petroleum gas um we have
systems in place to deal with natural
gas leaks uh we have training for our
officials and the same with um petroleum
fires like the major six alarm fire that
occurred in eping last week which was a
petroleum spill coming from internal
combustion engine vehicles um so there
are serious cost savings to to the
taxpayers of New Hampshire that may be
available by adopting um these types of
Technologies um and carbon pollution um
has been established as a pollution by
the state of New Hampshire um in this
past year because the state has accepted
um funding to do um several different
initiatives that specifically uh their
their goal and this is through um some
of the the um well the inflation
reduction act funding for our CL action
plan which our governor and our
executive Council decided to support and
accept um but also the um Volkswagen
fund specifically the the details of
those funds name that the goal of those
expenditures has to be to reduce carbon
pollution um so carbon pollution in
practice has been uh accepted as a
pollution within our state um and thank
you very much for for hearing my
testimony and happy to accept any
questions if there are
any
beny thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um how is the need
for Ev or hybrid plug-in hybrid from the
student body because Durham has the
large student body is there a big
request coming from out of state
students um so uh and I apologize I
can't speak into the microphone and
easily see you but um I would say that
at this point point no there's not been
um a large adoption by students of using
electric vehicles um we are seeing it
more from their family members that come
to visit or the University of New
Hampshire obviously receives a lot of
visitors and so um the town at this
point we have four town-owned um uh EV
Chargers and we have at least another
two that are operated by private
businesses um we have seen an increase
from just in the past year of 300 %
increase in the demand for the use of
those Chargers um and we're not able to
know though um whether that is coming
you know entirely locally or from out of
state but we are seeing an increased
demand um so I we do anticipate that the
demand will grow and that also um you
know UNH uh is looking at various
different um Technologies for its
vehicle Fleet um they share some of that
information with us and Durham you know
we continue to go by what is most cost
effective for the town um and and that
has been now for over a decade to go
hybrid wherever possible and now we're
starting to incorporate EV vehicles or
EVS thank
you all right thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
1333 seeing none I'll close the hearing
and open the hearing on House Bill 1580
it thank you for the record I'm
representative Tony leus representing
towns of Hudson and Lichfield uh
Hillsboro District 38 um the prime
sponsor representative n could not be
here and just asked me to introduce the
bill and that's all I'm doing I believe
there are other people here to uh speak
on
it um basically this would uh prohibit
the uh government procurement of
electric electric veh vehicles
containing components uh created through
in use of force labor and it goes on uh
to you know detail just what that means
and I really don't have anything else to
say on this all right thank
Paul
good morning thank you for having me uh
my name is Nick Paul I'm the director of
legislative affairs for clean energy New
Hampshire we're usually over in st& so
if you're not familiar with clean energy
New Hampshire uh we are a bipartisan
nonprofit 501c3
organization uh seeking to lead the
clean energy transition here in New
Hampshire looking at these issues
through a fact-based lens I don't have
prepared testimony today uh I'm going to
be uh very brief um because our position
on this bill is is fairly
straightforward uh the first point I
would make is that while uh there are
several thousand pure electric vehicles
in New Hampshire today uh forecasts from
ISO New England uh predict that by 2032
that number will be at least 165,000
there will be 2.2 million in surrounding
states and many more uh in Canadian
provinces uh so uh whether we personally
believe that electric vehicles are a
technology that's ready for prime time
or not uh they are coming and I I I'm
sure uh folks on this committee don't
need to be reminded that 2032 is not uh
way off into the future it's eight eight
years from now um the second thing is I
would like to talk a little bit about
Cobalt um Cobalt is used for many many
many many things that we use every day
um it's used in medicine uh it's used in
the manufacturing of Prosthetics it's
used uh in its Cobalt 60 form to treat
some forms of cancer and to sterilize
medical supplies uh as we know we're
talking about here today it's used in
lithium ion batteries that are used in
several different devices not just
electric vehicles uh it is used in
industry uh to make super Alloys for
turbine engine parts um it is used to
make magnets uh uh that are used in
microphones the connection to this bill
is hearing aids oh I I assure you I'm
bringing it right there uh hearing aids
microphones uh it is used in drying
agents for paints and varnishes and if
none of that is compelling because we're
not as a state procuring all of these
things right now right um I I would uh
want to make sure that you're aware that
Cobalt is also used to
manufacture uh airbags and radial tires
that are on uh I would assume all of the
internal combustion engine cars that we
uh used to get here today unless you
have a cool antique car in which case I
would love to check it out um so
uh bringing it back to this bill uh
we're not talking about any of those
other products today we're not talking
about the Cobalt that's being used in
our internal combustion engine cars
we're just talking about electric
vehicles right so we're targeting one
product um with which suggests to me
that perhaps we're not talking about
forced labor or child labor we're
talking about our our personal political
feelings about electric vehicles I would
suggest that folks uh look at Senate
Bill 430 which has been brought by
senator berdel in the Senate that looks
to study and understand uh the the real
challenges and questions we have to
answer in terms of electric vehicle
adoption again we are a nonpartisan
organization we do not pick technologies
that we like and ignore the problems
with them there are questions that need
to be answered that is a bill that I
would encourage folks to look at and
support uh I would encourage you to look
back on the testimony of the State Fire
Marshall during that bill which refutes
some of the misinformation on electric
vehicles that you've heard in this room
today um and I believe this afternoon
House Bill 1510 is being heard uh which
is a slightly different bill but again
is a is a
serious uh attempt to understand and
solve these
problems and that's all I have to say
Fitzgerald oh excuse me representative
Schmid you have a question well I Mr
Paul seems to have quite a bit of
knowledge that might be helpful to the
committee if we go to subcommittee I'm
just wondering whether you might be
available because um we need get at the
entire problem complex that is involved
here if we're going to make a
responsible decision for the state on
this and other
bills uh you're clearly informed would
you be available for assisting the
committee in our further research and
study of this issue if we go to
subcommittee uh certainly so I I
appreciate your your earnest uh
uh pursuit of more information I would
suggest that I'm not a technical expert
um but I my colleague Chris gogland who
heads our Drive Electric New Hampshire
initiative um would be more than happy
to make himself available to the
committee to answer your technical
questions about electric vehicles and
electric vehicle adoption we'd be more
than happy to help with that thank you
great thank you thank you m
Fredericks what happened to Mr oh F
sorry we still haven't gotten to Mr
that's good morning members of the
committee Madam chair again uh Mike
Fitzgerald with the Department of
Environmental Services I'm the assistant
director of the air Resources Division
my testimony on this bill uh largely
mirrors the testimony on the last bill
so I won't repeat that um but I would
would add that um we certainly concur
with the uh uh testimony you just heard
that there are a wide range of products
that we use today modern Electronics
vehicles um U medicine Etc um that have
many of these components that are of
concern uh it's not just related to
electric vehicles and so we would
question um why this bill targets only
electric vehicles um but uh uh we think
that's certainly a valid point but um
the rest of my testimony again would be
uh very similar to uh ask you to direct
your um uh these to potentially consider
interim study and uh U allow the s sp430
or hb1 1510 commissions to consider
these
issues thank
frericks
turn please turn your microphone on
thank you um em friedricks again uh from
350 New Hampshire action and also um
elected official in the town of Durham
um so uh while I really commend the um
this the co-sponsors of this bill for
wanting to take an an ethical approach
to State procurement uh I want to just
concur that um I think this B is not
really doing that because the large
majority of sourcing um of cobalt um is
not necessarily directed to electric
vehicles so um it seems to rather than
be really focusing on an ethical
approach to procuring materials um to
rather be looking for um a way to Target
electric vehicles and very specifically
how this would affect um for example
Durham taxpayers is that in this last
budget season we um received a $900,000
grant which is about 4% of our annual
budget um to help us uh fix and replace
our garbage truck Fleet um we needed to
procur three new vehicles um for our
garbage and recycling trucks and the
fund that helped us with that um was uh
distributed by the um nhdes and it was
the Volkswagen fund um so the town of
Durham and its taxpayers would suddenly
have a $900,000 gap in our budget a 4%
difference in our budget if the state
were not able to support um support the
procurement of electric vehicles and so
there are very real um uh consequences
for um State residents and for um the
budgets of um of other entities across
the state by um by putting forward a
bill like this um that's the if I'll
take any questions if you may have them
but that's all I wanted to add
representative Brown uh thank you madam
chair uh thank you could you clarify for
me what you just said if um if this
passes you wouldn't be able to spend the
$900,000 you received from
Dees I'm assuming because you're going
to buy electric waste Vehicles that's
the plan that's correct so um our public
works department did due diligence to
figure out what was most cost effective
for the town these were the models that
were selected um and we were able to pay
for that in our budget um we have not
yet received those funds so that's not
that the town currently holds them so if
this bill were to pass um and we hadn't
yet received the funds um we would be
short almost a million dollars which is
4% of our town
you does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 15 to
80 okay seeing none I will close the
hearing
and what's
up and I'd like to go into executive
session on House Bill 1580 and I will
entertain a motion Madam chair I make a
motion to itl House Bill
1580 do we have a
okay wish to speak to your
motion yes thank you madam chair
although perhaps well intentioned the um
bill um prohibits the use of other
materials in New Hampshire other than
electric vehicles I don't think it's
really well thought out and um that's my
that's why I'm making that motion repres
schm I don't have anything additional
other than what the prime mover has
suggested represent laus um well I you
know I may believe there are some
problems with how electric vehicles are
made I think that uh trying to solve
those problems by burdening the
procurement process with the job of
trying to figure it out and enforce it
is not the way to
go I would have to agree with
representative leus on that any other
representative
manuti thank you madam chair uh my
question is it's it's directed to
electric vehicle what percentage of
electric vehicles are manufactured and
assembled in the US and so that would
exclude
anything so this uh by putting a
Prohibition on procurement this would
make it harder to go forward with the
right we're not going to we're not we're
killing we would like to itl the bill so
that's not right yeah I I am supporting
the killing of the uh okay yes the
whether it's made or assembled in the US
they're talking
about constituent parts or mining or
other sourcing of any other materials
and the mining of many of the materials
people okay representative leus yeah
just briefly to clarify if you look at
uh the last section said it applies both
domestic and international Force labor
so it's uh it applies wherever the world
it takes
place all
right which is part of the problem with
the Department trying to figure this
out
would even if it were obvious what
materials were from Forced labor or
whatever it the documentation would be a
handicap to every town city county and
any other like us and just briefly I
mean um I really don't want to set the
precent of doing things this way because
it might be convenient to enforce almost
anything um by forcing the procurement
system to deal with it but that's just
not the way to go it's going to burn the
procurement system and there's if
somebody believes it's a problem then
there should be other laws whatever to
deal with it anyone
else okay then the motion is is itl by
representative
groer and the clerk can call the
role okay
um representative Boyd yes
representative
Brown yes the clerk votes yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative
goalie not here no he's right there yes
I'm here sorry yes on the motion
representative
Shu yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
Smith
yes representative mangi py yes I think
and representative leus I'm sorry yes
yes I think I'm Miss am I missing
somebody did I not call someone
they should be 12 oh I'm so sorry Mr ba
representative
Bailey yes okay this the vote is 12 to
nothing
okay uh the sponsor has asked us not to
put this on consent so I will we will
okay
about3 yeah I think so
okay considering House Bill
motion repres
repr I'll move interim
study
second who okay who was the second goie
go okay thank you do you wish to speak
to your
motion um sure Ian there are concerns
around um the electric vehicles it's not
clear it's a good idea for the state to
be procuring them although the the
fellow from do said that they they
haven't been um but given that there's
there may very well be um a commission
looking into the larger issues around
this um I'm fine with deferring to see
what happens with that and I'd rather
not do itl well it's not going to be the
second year but still um I don't know
that it's wrong so interim study seems
like a reasonable way to go all right
representa
goalie thank you madam chair well
understanding the issues uh surrounding
you
know the toxicities and the fires that
may happen with these vehicles um with
my expertise in the fire service um I
think that the bill out there that looks
to study these going forward to get all
the information needed um because it
sounds like there is a lot more
information to gather that it would be
better to wait for those two bills to
come forward um before moving this bill
okay does anyone else repr man buy uh a
just a quick comment about yes this is
studies needed but this is the second
year of the session so how effective is
the interim study in terms of getting it
well if we were to itl it were to pass
the house that would prohibit bringing a
similar bill in from the Senate
which which if they have studied it and
or gathered more information might not
be what you want thank
you representative
Smith the C thank thank you mad chair uh
excuse me I was represen representative
Schmid and she hasn't spoken
yet sorry I beg your pardon a thousand
times one is good enough okay Madame
chair thank you for calling on me um the
cost of replacing a battery is going to
be as expensive as buying a new vehicle
I think we need to think about that some
of these places that the fire
departments or the police departments or
even individuals if you buy a car and
you pay $75,000 for it and you have to
replace the battery within a couple of
years you're paying another 60 how many
people I granted it's good for the
environment I agree
but how many people can afford to
operate a an electric
vehicle and you have to put money into
building the places for them to plug in
along the
highways how practical is all of this
I'm not sure I regardless of the uh EPA
I'm not sure it's a expedient thing for
will
but not
yet thank you representative
Schmidt okay I have to get my ears fixed
I'm sorry I misunderstood you when you
called representative
Smith uh so this is clearly an extremely
involved situation which we need to get
a lot more information before we make a
wise decision so interim study would be
the the appropriate step to take in my
opinion I'll be voting yes on interim
study okay anyone
else don't see anybody in that case the
motion is interim study on House Bill
1333 and the clerk can call the role
representative luus yes representative
Bailey
yes okay representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes clerk votes yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shu
yes representative V Patrick yes
representative Smith yes representative
Mani py yes two three four five six and
the chair yes please okay so the quote
is 12 to zero for interim study does
anyone object to consent on this
one okay seeing none we'll put this one
on
consent and we'll come out of executive
session and and our next hearing starts
minutes
in the hearing on House Bill 1466 and
calling this Prime sponsor
representative
Aaron thank you madam
chair I do have some handouts so I'll
around
good morning adna members so good to see
you
again I am introducing this bill hb1
1466 to you today relative to providing
disaster relief funding to
disaster this past summer in July
2023 as well as in July 2021 many towns
experienced flooding due to heavy rains
in
2022 after the July 21 floods the
legislature passed s SP 409 which
provided for state funded disas to
relief loans to be accessible by
municipalities from the state treasury
after a federal disaster Declaration was
made by the president of the United
States this was basically to help them
pay for repair work essentially Tiding
them over until reimbursement is
received from FEMA the problem with this
method is that it is wholly unworkable
and ex inexpedient for the municipality
for a few reasons number
one you have to wait many weeks and
often months for a federal disaster
declaration to be made by the president
of the United States towns don't have
the luxury of waiting weeks and months
to make their roads passable and safe
you cannot access State loan money until
a federal disaster is
declared number two the timing to obtain
a loan from the state is way too long
considering a municipality cannot get a
loan until they get approval from the
town
voters that involves setting up a town
meeting it can take two months for a
town meeting to get arranged especially
if a bond attorney is needed by the town
for obtaining a state loan plus a
special town meeting can be a huge
expense for a small town this is
problematic for towns who wish to get
the zero interest loans from the state
as per RSA
2-p colon 37 hyphen C for further
legislation would be needed to
streamline this special town meeting
process in the event of a natural
disaster it took aworth 66 days to get
permission to hold and schedule a
special town meeting in 2021 and I've
passed out um a paper that shows you the
timeline of how that
happened that was back in 2022 when our
state was flush with arpa funding a
healthy
Surplus yet aworth couldn't get any
immediate financial help from the
state from the loan process set up by S
sp4 in 2022 sought to fix that but it
that didn't work there was and still is
no other emergency statutory vehicle to
help municipalities get back on their
feet quickly so in 2022 aworth had to go
get help elsewhere we held a town
meeting to authorize a 2.1 loan dollar a
$2.1 million loan from Mesa Bank who was
willing to work with us it is
2024 and we are still struggling to pay
back that loan along with the $40,000
interest because FEMA reimbursement has
been so excruciatingly
slow musoma bank has been patient and
has been working with the town and our
town has enormous Financial challenges
facing us and 10 roads are still
closed since s sp49 was ped I don't know
of any town that has gotten any state
loan after a flooding event aworth
didn't even apply for the state loan
after the 2023 flood because the process
wasn't even in place and because we had
already exceeded the amount the town
could borrow and also because we didn't
want to incur the expense of another
meeting number three the reimbursement
for FEMA can take years it's been three
years since the July 2021
flood and we've still not received all
the reimbursement for the work that's
been done in the meantime we had that
other flood in July 2023 that washed
away all the work that we did to repair
the roads from the 2021 flood had we
gotten all the financial help we needed
to get repairs done from the 2021 flood
we wouldn't have had so much more damage
in 2023 the fact is small towns like
aworth that have about 850 people cannot
absorb the kind of damage done overnight
by these kinds of natural
disasters they could save money for 20
whole because they just don't have the
tax base and the resources to recover
from
it Decades of investment in their roads
and bridges were demolished in one night
causing issues concerning safety
Commerce and environment and quality of
life and I can tell you that my town
suffered millions of dollars of road
damage Bridge damage and crop damage
Road repair work has been slow and
expensive and not all of it is eligible
for FEMA reimbursement on top of that
FEMA only pays to put the road back to
the condition it was before the disaster
event so there may not even be coverage
for mitigation efforts for larger
culverts or Road diversion to prevent
similar destruction from reoccurring and
number four towns need access to funding
as quickly as possible especially when
the window of time to do construction
work before the winter may be short
again again current processes are
extremely time consuming and I can tell
you after the July 2021 flooding in
aworth Dees and Homeland Security
emergency management did not come until
September 8th 2021 to assess damage a
full month and a half after the floods
hit us yet in that time period we had to
make roads passable not only for
emergency vehicles but are for our
citizens safety we literally had one
road available to get in and out of town
for a time and currently at after the
July 2023 floods we still have 10 roads
that are closed and a totally destroyed
bridge that won't be repaired for
another two years I have a crater and an
impassible bridge at the bottom of my
driveway and every time I have asked
about getting immediate State financial
help from municipality that has suffered
incredible loss due to this kind of
extreme flooding I get the same answer
we have AA available funds in the state
but no statutory vehicle to get any kind
of emergency funding to a municipality
so here I am today with a plan to create
a statutory vehicle we have a fund
already established let's put money in
it and allow towns that need help after
disaster to access it I know there are
some Kinks that need to be worked out
but I'm open to any amendments to fix
them especially as it relates to the
funding timing and approval process
through the fiscal committee Etc and
just as presidential Declaration of
emergency is the trigger for federal
funds to be made available able I'm
proposing that the commissioner of
Department of Safety declare a natural
disaster in the state which would allow
municipalities to apply for grant
funding from the existing emergency
response and Recovery Fund that's in RSA
21-
p46 this bill amends that RSA to include
municipalities to be able to access
funding we can put money into this fund
from our rainy day fund it would go a
long way to help municipalities get back
on their feet more quickly than waiting
months and years for anything to come
from the federal government FEA
reimbursement program I've put some
Provisions in the bill which would
ensure that only towns with significant
damage and with limited resources can
get assistance as for the notion that if
a town gets State grant money they may
be ineligible to receive FEMA
funding I can tell you that towns I
represent are tired and disgusted in
working with femma it's been a
bureaucratic Nightmare and they don't
get back nearly as much money as is they
put in claims for they simply don't have
the town staff or time to deal with FEMA
they're telling me that they would much
rather have a state program in place to
help them and they feel it would be more
expedient and efficient other states do
this and I would also add that with the
very poor response time of FEMA
reimbursement and the overall horrendous
FEMA
bureaucracy um we need to change this
FEMA has made statements about their
programs running low on funds so the
wait times might be even longer in the
them as for the notion
um oh wait a state program like what I'm
proposing is by In This bipartisan bill
would go a long way to helping a small
town with little resources to begin to
rebuild after a natural disaster and
make roads and other infrastructure safe
for its citizens and businesses so I
hope that you'll consider what I present
today today it's time we allow the state
to step in to help a municipality in
time of need I asked also that you look
over the link that I sent to you all via
email a report from the Pew trust about
how States pay for natural disasters in
this era of rising costs it's
Illuminating to see how poorly New
Hampshire fares against other states and
lastly reports indicate that the
expenditures for the Federal Emergency
Management agency's public assistance
program which municipality seek
reimbursement from after a natural
disaster alone increased by 23% When
comparing the
20209 and 2010 to 2019 decades the
federal government as a whole spent at
least $460 billion on disaster costs
from 2005 to 2019 we're already hearing
that FEMA is beginning to run out of
reimbursement money and they're backing
away from funding reimbursement requests
as a state we have to be prepared to
help ourselves we should start that
process and I thank you appreciate your
time and I'm open for any
questions thank
you representative
Shu thank you madam chair thank you
representative Aaron um I'm curious um
if at any point during this um these two
floods particularly if either your town
or you as a representative your town of
your town reached out to our
Congressional Delegation to see if they
could accelerate uh FEMA and Homeland
Security response yes we have and they
haven't been able to do anything thank
you and um I mean to their credit down
in uh New Hampshire Homeland Security
emergency management director Rob
buckton has been incredible he's been
doing a lot of work to help um run
interference
with between the municipality and
between FEMA uh and trying to get
FEMA you know they they had a lot of PE
they've changed the way they do things
too and they they had a constant bunch
of people in and out of the project so
there was always we always had to spend
time bringing people up to speed which
was a waste of time too we gave them
documentation that they lost three four
five six
times um it's just been miserable to
work with them but again I would say
director buckton has also done a really
good job in so far as a lot of the rules
that FEMA uh has us follow or
information that they are requesting
from
us SI simply is just not
um it's difficult for or even impossible
for municipality to provide that
information
and so he has tried in various ways to
get exemptions when we are required to
give certain documents or certain
information whatever and so he's done a
really good job in trying to accelerate
accelerate the process and also trying
to find ways in which we may be exempt
from certain things that they're asking
for so yes I mean we've tried what we
can to help move things along but it's a
huge bureaucracy aworth and towns in New
Hampshire who have experienced flooding
are not the only ones who are requesting
reimbursement from FEMA we have all
kinds of disasters and things happening
all over the country and I have to tell
you
too um I a couple of months ago I had um
the opportunity to speak with Governor
Ronda santis of Florida and I spoke to
him and asked him because Florida gets
hit with uh disasters all the time
and I asked him so what does your state
do do you do you help municipalities do
you help individuals what how do you how
do you handle this he said well we got
tired of waiting for FEMA and granted
it's Florida it's a much bigger State
than New Hampshire but he said we set up
our own $500 million fund and when
there's a bridge that needs to be
replaced after a hurricane or something
we take money out of that fund and we
replace it right away especially if it's
in a highly trafficked area or very
important to Commerce he said if we need
housing for people to live in like an RV
or some other um
small um house or something we provide
that funding for those families while
their house is being rebuilt so there
are states and and in this Pew report
that I um I sent you the link to it it
it shows that different states handle
these natural disasters differently in
terms of the way they fund um they may
have reimbursement programs Grant
programs loan programs there's all
different kinds of things that are
offered to the municipalities and the
citizens of their states and I find that
New Hampshire is sorely lacking in that
we have completely put ourselves um to
depend on FEMA
reimbursement and while like I said sp
sp 409 allows for a loan
program that is also um a
time time um
sensitive process you have to wait a
couple of months before you can have a
special election to get a loan it's not
like the um select board in your town
can say oh we're going to go take a loan
we're going to go get money they can't
do that without the voters saying
so okay I have so two questions sure the
first one is that it looks as though the
department of safety requires five
people to implement
this
um is was that your intention and if so
it well you know I hadn't uh I I hadn't
talked to Department of Safety as to
whether or not you know what they would
need in terms of resources to Implement
such a
program but I don't know how they need
five people to do that I mean you have
the the commissioner who can see they
already have people in uh New Hampshire
Homeland Security emergency management
that work on these
disasters I don't know how they would
need five more people to implement any
kind of grant program to help towns okay
thank you the other question question is
as was pointed out in the fiscal note
that you required the department of
safety to make emergency funds available
within 24 hours after approval of fiscal
which meets once a month yeah I saw that
and that's I that's something that I
would need to fix in this bill um
perhaps we wouldn't have to go prob
perhaps the uh the director of Homeland
Security emergency management can
anticipate how much funding he may need
to put into this existing fund and go to
fiscal and have that
funded and then having the money in the
fund we can make those funds available
to municipalities right away you
wouldn't have to go through fiscal
committee for that so I think there's a
there's an element in the bill here that
I do need to fix and I don't know if I
do
that within this committee here or if
this goes off to finance
after I'm not sure how that concerned
about that and I'm I would be very
concerned if you tried to fix it so that
the commissioner of emerg of Homeland
Security could had a multi-million
dollar fund he could just give away to
towns without any
oversight I get that and that's
something I'd be willing to work with um
someone from fiscal or someone from
finance committee to fix in this Bill
okay thank you because I think you know
we have a fund that's there it does as
far as I know right now there's only
$45,000 in it and um I think if we have
a fund we ought to make some put some
money in it and make some grants
available to municipalities who really
need it in their time of
need okay um this will be going to
representative shu's
subcommittee and we will um um since
it's an early Bill we need to meet soon
because it has to be exact by the middle
of February okay but I'd be willing to
sit down and you know work through that
that timing issue and um money
allocation issue okay yes I those are
issues y okay any other questions
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair well I I I I was a moment late in
coming back into the room so I missed
something at the very beginning of your
uh
testimony uh but um I I
recall looking around uh I think maybe
representative Shu was here at the time
but when alad had the infamous flood
about 18 years ago I think um it was
actually during the off season I think
it was like in the in July or August or
something like that and I mean the
center of town was just ripped out by
the the river getting damned up and then
the the the the that dam broke if you
will and it it just ripped the center of
town completely out but we had a special
session and we we took action very
quickly that was under Governor Lynch uh
and I'm wondering uh this is clearly a
major issue and a FEMA has been so I me
functionally derelict um in and acting
on behalf of aor um then we got to do
something so uh the the idea of a more
coordinated and expanded effort I think
is appropriate so seems like the
subcommittee the chairs selected is
going to be helpful for that so um and
you you already indicated that you're
willing to make some changes to so yeah
good okay and I might add you know this
isn't just an aworth issue we've seen
just in this past July 2023 floods a lot
more um municipalities were hit with
severe flooding and problems with their
infrastructure um so I think that it's
time that we we look as a at a state to
be a little bit more serious about um
taking on some of the responsibilities
of helping the these towns through this
and while home Homeland Security
emergency management in New Hampshire
has been really great in um their
response in helping us and guiding us
through the whole bureaucratic um moras
from FEMA um I think if we could do
something simpler and more expedient for
ourselves in the state that would be to
our credit I mean
um you know events like
this though are they're hardest on our
smallest towns that have small tax bases
and limited
resources and you know I believe New
Hampshire spirit is to lend a helping
hand where it's needed so I I would hope
that we can do
something I certainly think it's a it's
worth a uh concerted effort to see if we
can't improve the mechanism of
addressing these issues as opposed to
kind of waiting for the FED federal
government has got a much much deeper
pockets of course we all know that but
but to the degree that it's it's not a
very functional or Speedy uh resolution
of the issue we got to try something so
and I I had had um discussions with
representative Wier from finance and he
uh he indicated to me when I was asking
you know does a state have funding to do
this he said I could give you $4 million
tomorrow and allocate that funds for you
but there's no statutory mechanism to do
it and I kept hearing that from the
governor's office I kept hearing that
from the Senators Jeb Senator Bradley um
there's just no statutory mechanism
other than the loan process which again
is very limited because a town can only
take out a loan for as much as they are
uh they're available to do based on what
their assets are and everything else uh
and and the process is more lengthy it
takes a couple of months to get a a
special uh town meeting
going okay thank you is there anyone
1466 all right seeing none thank you
representative Aaron thank you so much
for taking the time and listening to me
and I'd be happy to work with your
subcommittee and coming up with uh
something that's more fiscally uh
workable okay Madam chair if I
just add uh since both your community
and mine were involved in the famous
Mother's Day aulion for our towns and
neighboring towns uh we're very
sympathetic to this and I hope we can
get something worked out okay okay thank
you very much all right in that case I'm
going to close the hearing we're due
back at 1:15 for green
brials yum yes exactly get your lunch
first
and this will this will be going going
to
subcommittee
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
montine uh hello I'm Jessica lontine a
representative from
do and I thank you for letting me
present here
today I I want to talk about how uh this
bill came into being briefly and also go
over some of the basic concepts about
green burials and natural organic
reduction as well as general practices
we have about burial and death
care um so I first uh started thinking
about this because last friend a uh last
spring a good family friend passed away
in
Vermont and he had already made himself
a pine casket and one for his wife and
he was buried on his own land in a very
remote place of
Vermont and I found that to be such a
moving experience and it got me thinking
a lot
about my own family's experience with
how we've handled death my grandparents
had open casket wakes and were in bombed
and I remember as a child that that was
not a positive experience for
me and both my parents have opted for
cremation and I hadn't really thought
much about what I would like for myself
and most of us don't it's not a subject
that is talked about
though we will all have
to experience that
ultimately um but what at this friend's
funeral um our mutual friend said oh you
know Jeff worked really hard to change
thew laws in Vermont so that he could
have this green burial and I thought
well I'm a State Rep I think I'm going
to look at what the laws are in New
Hampshire and so I've done a lot of
research and talking about it talking
about it with um my
colleagues and so a lot of them are here
today I was worked especially hard with
will uh Darby and Allison knob on this
project and they're both here
today so
and that's how the um it evolved to also
include natural organic reduction not
just green
barrial so I chose to have a slideshow
because you know pictures can hopefully
save us a lot of words well but why why
have a build on green burials in natural
organic reduction there's growing
interest in alternatives to Conventional
burials and
cremation their green burial and natural
organic reduction are ways of carrying
ing for the Dead with minimal
environmental impact it aids in the
conservation of Natural
Resources both reduce carbon emissions
protect worker health help restore or
preserve natural
space there's a lot of resources used um
and other drawbacks to Conventional
burial they take up valuable space in
our cities and
towns and bombing fluids are highly
toxic morticians who do this work have
eight times the leukemia rate as the
general population and 13 times the rate
of early death due to many other
diseases and we also potentially
contaminate the soil and groundwater
with these
toxins and caskets and B also take up
valuable
resources hardwood Steel and concrete
ground in many ways green burial is
returning to the way humans have buried
their loved ones for
Millennia really interrupted only in the
last
century yeah this shows a a photo of a
grave that's it's not that deep um and
people have scattered flowers and it's
clearly in a wild
location
green burial cemeteries um have been
growing in recent
years and this this shows a chart just
um in the last 18 years or so how it's
continued to grow and I passed out one
of the handouts is a list of all the
green cemeteries in the state of New
Hampshire and when I first saw this list
I was surprised there weren't any in
do my town and only till to learn that
um we actually the Quaker Cemetery in do
was on the list at one point and that
congregation asked to be taken off the
list because they're getting so many
calls from people asking if they could
be buried there and they felt they
weren't really equipped that to handle
that
demand
sorry so HB 1324
introduces new definitions to the
chapter on
cemeteries what is a natural burial it
means the interment of an unembalmed
human remains or human remains embalmed
using non-toxic and bombing fluids and
that rest in a non-toxic non-hazardous
plant derived disposition container or
shroud and this is a picture of two
caskets that would break down relatively
quickly you know wicker or a pine casket
yes representative you don't really need
to read the slides to us since you're
providing all of them okay yes I do have
the handouts mhm
okay oops
sorry um I also found out that green
barar is are already legal in New
Hampshire um so you can have one in your
backyard if you want to but that's not
really practical unless you live on a
land that's not going to be developed um
because
we can see what happens uh to some old
field but most people would like to be
buried in the cemetery and our statutes
require that municipalities provide a
cemetery for for people to be buried in
in their Town yeah I went over the list
of green
burials
already but HB 1324 also Al defines what
a natural burial ground
is um the the the main reason you know
so green Barrow is already legal in New
Hampshire but the main reason it's hard
to get one is the cemetery bylaws
prohibit it by still
requiring uh vaults and this is a
picture of a whole stack of vaults in a
warehouse the vault is what requires the
burial to be so much deeper commonly
referred to as 6 feet
under um actually the the law that was
changed in Vermont the only thing they
had to change was the burial depth they
had a statute that the grave had to be I
think it was five or six feet
deep um but that's not ideal for green
burial um other things that the alts do
is they um they increase the depth and
width that's needed the width as well
and a lot of that's just for running the
lawnmowers and to prevent the ground
from
sinking but with the grain
burial you really want to be about 3 and
1/2 ft underground which allows for
natural decomposition to
happen um and you could
pile um more organic material on top or
soil a big Mound on top of the Grave
gradually and this is a picture from the
Green Mountain Cemetery in M pear
Vermont where they've chosen just to
have a more natural way of managing the
grounds and not mowing it
tight uh like a playing field or golf
course but just let it grow a little
wild and bushwack it once or twice a
year
you know all cemeteries take up a lot of
space but we we think they're going to
be there forever but they're probably
not um you know this is a picture of the
catacombs in Paris where they they had
to dig up a lot of cemeteries and move
the bones to a big underground
chamber a friend of mine went back to
Switzerland where his mother had died 40
years or so before so he went to visit
her grave and he was told he couldn't
find it and they said well that's that's
gone now we we after 35 years we just
remov that grave and he couldn't really
get an explanation of what happened to
her
remains but the the other alternative to
burial is to really leave leave no
pernament Monument to our
lives and reducing the body to ashes or
soil which leads us to
Cremation which is now the most common
means of final disposition in New
cremation and why is cremation
increasing in popularity it's it's
cheaper doesn't take up space in a
cemetery space is less available than it
used to and you have more options for
what you decide to do with the op the
the
ashes but you could see that um
cremation in a way it's very um it's
like death sort of
disappears for me I spent a lot of time
with my dad right up to the end of his
life when he
died and then when he went to be
cremated we weren't even it wasn't
suggested that we go along and witness
that
process at all it's he was just gone and
then a couple weeks later we we got the
the
ashes where with a a natural bars more
gentle I think I think of it as a gentle
disposition that family members can
witness um this is just a little more
of you can also choose to bury ashes
cremated ashes in a cemetery as well or
columbarium but why not
cremation why would we want an
alternative to that since it's so
popular well it uses a lot of fossil
fuels to burn a body at a really high
temperature andits a lot of CO2 into the
air it uses a lot of fuel up and it
creates air
pollution locally and can release um
heavy metals and other elements into the
air which leads us to natural organic
reduction which can be seen as an
alternative to
Cremation likewise it's considered the
final
disposition and instead of getting ashes
soil so HP 1324
authorizes natural organic reduction and
we have definitions of that in the
cemetery chapter as well as the soil
that results and a big part of that long
bill you received is a new chapter under
325 which is under the funeral
director's um chapter to establish how
The Lure and oversight of natural
organic reduction will happen in New
Hampshire and it's modeled very much
after the chapter on
cremation I think we would all agree
that when it comes to handling dead
bodies that we would want it carefully
regulated and
overseen a natural organic reduction is
now legal in seven
states and there's legislation underway
in many states especially in New
Hampshire
now um and it's a new means of
disposition
of human remains though the science
behind it has been used for composting
decades and how it
works I don't know if you want me to go
through this at all but I think people
really don't understand but the body's
placed in a
vessel wrapped in cotton or wood shroud
wool shroud and laid on a bed of organic
material and in a cemetery friends can
add flowers and they can have or other
meaningful organic material
to into the
chamber and air and water is sometimes
pumped in the vessel to create ideal
conditions for
decomposition and these are naturally
microbes that are in the body and the
soil naturally go to work and break
everything down and its temperature and
the air flow are carefully monitored and
controlled
and any gases are filtered out before
being
released and then a month and a half or
so the body is completely transformed at
the end there are just bones left there
might be medical implants that are
filtered out and remaining bones are
ground into a powder and a cremulator
which is what happens in cremation as
well it's the same
technology and the soil is car carefully
tested for heavy metals and any bacteria
it's usually stored for a month or
two and then the resulting soil though
is about a cubic yard of material
because so much other matter was added
to the
vessel and I'm going to show some slides
here that were provided by
recompose which was really the first
operator for natural organic reduction
in the state of Washington and the
picture here is Katrina Spade who's a
New Hampshire n um
Native and she founded this
company so you have these in your um the
handout but it basically goes over the
same
process and this fall I was out in the
Pacific Northwest visiting family so I
made a point of of touring the recompose
facility I took this picture they
operate as a funeral home so the
cemeteries I mean I'm sorry the
ceremony um is run like the funeral
there and this is a picture of like the
ceremonial chamber in the room while
they'll have the ceremony and then it's
transferred to the back
room for the
process and this is a picture of the
soil which the resulting material is
safe and Rich and you can use it on
Gardens um and families can choose well
I'll skip over some of that because you
have
that um but there's really careful
recordkeeping in Seattle and other
states where it's
legalized for both the chain of custody
for the body and the
soil and um temperature soil testing
this is another um vessel from a
Washington so of the soil some people
would take it home just like they would
pick up ashes and bring it home and at
that point it's not considered a body
anymore there actually aren't any traces
of of
DNA remaining so it can be planted in
your own garden if you want but most
people aren't going to take a pickup
truck full of material home so most of
the operators will donate that soil to a
um a land conservation program or
reforest
station
and and this is a picture of some of the
land where the unclaimed soil from
recomposed goes and each of those little
sapling so I just want to review what HB
1324 does not do is mandate green
burials it does not prohibit and bombing
or conventional
burials it doesn't change any laws
regarding cemeteries or burials we just
have added more definitions to the
cemetery chapter and it does not
authorize Al Aline
hydrolysis what it does do is offer
greater choice for New Hampshire
residents and addition to Conventional
burial and natural burial and Flame
cremation and what happens to our bodies
after
death it will hopefully facilitate more
cemeteries to adopt green green burial
ideas if they choose and it clarifies
scattering Gardens and rights in
Memorial
forests
so I am uh open to any
questions representative
sh thank you madam chair um I have quite
a few questions actually um I'm assuming
that um you are talking about possibly
being incorporated into cemeteries that
already exist within our
municipalities not just new uh
cemeteries is that true
do you mean the soil or well you talk
about green cemeteries yes uh and I'm
I'm looking and you don't change any of
the existing for example 289 colon 2
which says that Municipal cemeteries are
subject to the regulations of the
municipality so each municipality would
then have to change its rules or
ordinances in in order to allow that is
that true that is correct Okay and like
I have already gone to the Dober
Cemetery
board to promote the idea of changing
their Cemetery laws but it's is not a
state mandate that every municipality
has to but each municipality would have
to make uh changes in order to allow it
yes okay U followup followup um I'm also
concerned um you talk about being able
to do a burial on your own private
property um would there be some kind of
stipulation that if and when that
property changes hands if it gets sold
that the new buyer should be informed
that yes that is existing statute that
you may bury you may may be buried on
your own property and you do have to
record that grave on the deed so future
residents know but that's already in
statute okay thank you and follow follow
up um on page one line
22 uh talking about um crated remains or
natural organic
reduction uh can be mixed with or placed
on top of the soil or ground and I
understanding that this would be placed
on top of the ground not covered in any
way that might be and that in that case
we are talking about the
soil so it it is
not once natural or redu organic
reduction has taken place that's
considered the final disposition it's
not considered a body
anymore and it the material can be
treated as
soil as soil okay okay and it's so
there is there any concern that that
would um attract animals that might be
attracted
to no more than any other soil would be
there's really no Trace left of what was
a body thank
you represent leus this is kind of a
maybe clarification question for what
representative Shu asked so you said if
you know it's put on private land
there's still there's current statute
about recording that but if it's not
considered a body and it's just soil is
that really required now that well you
have to record if you're burying a body
if you're making a
grave so with the soil it's not
considered a body
anymore people routinely scatter ashes
that we have nothing in statute about
their right to do that which we actually
do in here we did clarify that you have
a right to scatter ashes or the soil on
private property with
permission and likewise if you were to
donate it the soil to a a conservation
land
um you that would that you could have an
arrangement to do that whether it's a a
a green Cemetery where they may use the
soil as fill cemeteries actually are
looking for fill all the time um you
know my husband and I are uh work in
construction and we once had a chimney
taken down and we're trying to find a
way like wow it's a very expensive thing
to bury and someone said oh just go ask
Tom Duffy the grav digger he takes the
bricks and sure enough we delivered the
bricks to the cemetery which we used to
fill in holes so this would be an
alternative of perhaps some more
appropriate material to fill in holes in
the
cemetery because it's just soil and if
people want to take it to a place that
they consider sacred or
protected a cemetery might be a good
place to take
that great thank
you representative Brown thank you madam
chair um
composting sludge from wastewater
treatment plants which can have
pathogens from humans requires some
significant monitoring and certain steps
that have to be reached in temperature
and time to assure that you have
pathogen reduction yes I would assume
the potential is there from any any
human remain so is that incorporated
maybe maybe it will be come up later but
yes we we did not put in the chapter
very specific things about
how the soil will be tested and
monitored but it's clear that um since
it would be
regulated by
oplc um that those rules could be set up
and could be modeled
after how the process is done in other
states where they do the testing and the
state does not pay for the testing the
operator assumes all the cost it's just
um checked on by the
state thank you representative leus
thank you so uh in the I haven't care I
don't remember the whole thing but is
there someone here that deals with that
issue that he just raised uh that
actually gives oplc 541a rul making
authority to to come up with those rules
is that in
here you know that I I am not sure about
that we we did ask when we worked with
OS and drafting this they wanted to be
sure that all their recent changes in Ru
making that they have for cremation were
included in this bill so I'm not sure
about the exact wording of that but I
will look into it was my understanding
that that would happen yes thank you yes
yes there it's on page 11 Ru making
Authority that gives the board authority
including um lure
requirements uh Public Health
requirements sanitation and inspection
requirements yeah I thought it was in
there but I wasn't quite
sure
okay representative
MTI thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question
question you in your presentation you
alluded to the fact that embodying uh
EMB bombing does use chemicals and that
leeches once the body is buried it's
already
leeching some toxins how is that
measured who is responsible for that in
a
cemetery that I do not know um
we have someone from the funeral
director's board who might be able to
answer that sort of technical question
that's that's about current status and
current law not not this
Dees okay any other
questions all right thank you very much
Darby
no
okay need yes represent Montaine if you
would fill out a pink card we'd
appreciate
it
Glenn that's the same Glenn that's the
same
thing pleas thank you uh um chair
McGuire honorable members of the
committee my name is Will Derby I'm
representative from national award 8
thank you for allowing me to testify uh
on behalf of HB 1325 this this
afternoon like many of us as we age I
recently began to think about life Derby
could you please speak into the
microphone it's very hard to hear you
yes thank
you
um like many of us uh as we age I
recently began to think about life's end
and the arrangement of my remains as an
Outdoorsman and conservationist my goal
was to give back to the Earth that has
given so much to me and I thought uh
cremation and spreading the resultant
ashes would enrich the soil and allow my
wife and family to plan it free using
them in my memory I was dispayed
dismayed to learn that cremated remains
have high alkaline and sodium content
that is harmful to plants and must be
neutralized before being used in
plantings not exactly giving back to the
Earth the way that I had hoped with a
little research I learned a burgeoning
technique called natural organic
reduction which literally produces soil
and can be used for planting a tree at
home or rejuvenating a conservation
Forest elsewhere in New Hampshire while
natural organic reduction is legal in
seven states New Hampshire only allows
bodies to be buried cremated or donated
to science and I was not looking to
leave the state I
love as I learned more I was excited to
find natural organic reduction provides
a myriad of benefits for example no soil
which results from the process does not
take up Cemetery space which many
communities are struggling to make
available as required by law as a soil
can be taken home by loved ones uh for
use in for example flower gardens or
spread in conservation land like
Memorial
forests ecological benef benefits in my
opinion are another important reason to
F to favor natural organic reduction
over conventional methods of remains
disposition not notably a dramatic
reduction in carbon emissions and use of
other materials such as EMB bombing
fluids concrete and steel while New
Hampshire does permit green burials
there are few green cemeteries in the
state and I personally want my family to
be able to have a permanent reminder at
home ultimately this bill is about
choice and provide providing choices to
families and to funeral service
consumers as to how to honor their loved
ones after they're passing this is
simply an enabling bill that does not
alter limit existing disposition methods
in any way
and does not add requirements to funeral
homes that choose not to offer natural
organic reduction to their clients
instead this bill allows runer homes to
work with one of the five companies
nationally that provide no to make these
services available in their facility or
through a partnership following the
approach used for Cremation Services
numerous Studies have found green burial
options to be widely popular with over
50% of people in pursuing green burials
and techniques like natural organic
production some experts even even
believe this Market will mature into a
billion dollar industry over
time many people are not familiar with
natural granic reduction and as I have
talked to other Representatives friend
friends and constituents I've often been
asked a few questions such as what
happens to the bones the nolr process
breaks down the body into nutrient-rich
soil and eliminates all traces of DNA
however as with cremation bone fragments
remain which are reduced into
unidentified Dem un identifiable
dimensions and added back to the
resultant soil to provide additional
nutrients this is similar to the process
um used for cremation rins um it also
includes removing non- Organics like
implants what about diseases and
bacteria the NR process heats the body
to temperatures exceeding 131 degrees
for several days eliminating pathogens
the resultant soil is tested for
contaminants including testing for salon
salmonella to ensure pathogens have been
destroyed prior to releasing the no soil
to the family for worker safety um this
uh service cannot be provided to those
with a few rare diseases such as Ebola
or tuberculosis or those with radiation
seed does the process smell the no U
natural organic reduction does not smell
as microorganisms break down resultant
gases into carbon dioxide and water and
filters eliminate remaining ERS
additionally this bill allows a
municipality to restrict the location of
no facilities as it does as happens
today for cremation facilities um and
also requires sending notice to nearby
Property Owners prior to establishing an
no facility no soil is exactly like
other compost in texture and
odor what happens to the soil the no
process results in approximately
approximately one cubic yard of soil
about the volume of a pickup truck bed
as organic materials are added to help
with the
transformation while families can take
all of the uh soil from their loved ones
remains they typically opt for small
portion to plant a tree or use in a
garden as a memorial an soil cannot be
sold or used for growing food instead
remaining soil is usually donated to
conservation force with establishment
with established agreements uh with the
no facility this bill requires the no
operator to notify the family as to the
disposition of unclaimed or
soil this bill was drafted following
consultation with industry experts the N
uh New Hampshire Funeral Directors
Association oplc and the board of
funeral directors and EMB bombers the
licensure model is uh directly derived
from that used for cremation which
requires Ru making by the board to
regulate no authorities no facilities
and no
operators while this bill contains a
fiscal note oplc indicated the cost
related to licensing could be absorbed
in their existing budget
as rules must be adopted before natural
organic reduction can be licensed there
are no near-term expenditures if natural
organic reduction became wildly popular
to the level of adoption of cremation
today additional staff for a clerk and
inspector Could Be Imagined but
realistically in the foreseeable future
a very small number of no oper oper
facilities maybe only one would be
introduced which could in all likelihood
be handled by opl C's existing staff
thank you for your attention and
interest in this bill I hope you agree
this bill simply provides more options
to remember and honor our loved ones as
well as opening new markets to Funeral
Home operators of course I'll be happy
to take
questions repr
black uh thank you um just
curious just in general terms what's the
cost of doing this compared to let's say
cremation um so cremation um at the low
end of cremation I understand is about 2
,000 um the average price that I've read
um can be up to about
$6,000 um a full burial is um the
average price I've read is $8 to $9,000
this is going to fall in the 8,000 about
$8,000 range good thank you
okay thank you very much for your
oh sorry D excuse me
thank you just just briefly um there's a
reference uh in your uh paper about um
bodies with a radiation seed is that one
of those items where they try and Trace
through your body various um am I
understanding that
correctly to to be uh truthful I'm not a
medical expert in this area but what I
did read is is that um active radiation
in the body for example if you have an
active seed that is irradiating or
you've had act uh very recent radiation
treatment would disqualify the body so
okay that was my next question if you
have gone undergone radiation for cancer
treatment and so forth that would
disqualify you it it would um it would
be within something like the last 30
days I can't recall the exact timeline
but um normal radiation like for cancer
dissipates over time the this radiation
seed as I understand it something they
actually implant in the body that
actively um actively radiates the body
and so because it's act there's an
active radiation at the time of death
that would disqualify the body as if you
the same way as if you had a radiation
treatment the week before you
passed thank you thank
you okay Mr
Moren
that's there we go uh good sorry good
afternoon uh representative Maguire and
and members of the committee uh my name
is Peter Moren I am the executive uh uh
director of the New Hampshire funeral
directors and bombers Association here
in New Hampshire you may have seen me
another committee hearings in the past
uh and uh I'm also a licensed New
Hampshire field director n Balmer and uh
I've been doing this for the association
for the past 16 years and I'm here today
on behalf of the association to speak in
opposition to the bill the way it's
written uh initially we met with the the
sponsors of the bill back last fall and
we did have some discussions with them
initially it looked at first glance to
be pretty straightforward but then the
more I researched that and and really
dug into it um having lost my brother
back in September there was a period
there where I wasn't really doing a lot
but I've uh I'm back on on my uh on
track again here and we've really
researched this very carefully and um
let me just uh get my things here watch
my notes here so I don't drift off
um and what I'm here to represent is the
concerns and questions from our members
we had our our uh our annual meeting
back on uh January 14th uh 13th actually
in Meredith New Hampshire and over half
of the fial directors in the state were
there for our annual meeting um the
overall uh concerns which I'll address
here briefly um were raised U that there
was a general consensus that there was
no need for this that they hadn't seen a
demand for this or any interest in it uh
and there were concerns about custody
and control and about uh chain of
custody and basically the other things
that came up in our our discussions were
potential environmental ISS issues um I
guess primarily is
that and I like to use the term human as
composting you know we have where great
ones even Funeral Directors were guilty
of using a lot of euphemisms you know we
like to it makes it sound nicer and
everything we call it natural organic
reduction um you know that could be what
occurs in a green barrial could be
occurs in any number of situations but
um our concern here too is that the term
natural organic reduction and no which
are always
capitalized um is it could be a
copyrighted term could be owned by
someone uh I haven't researched that we
want I would we would prefer that
generic terms be used and call it human
composting the previous statute 325A
which is our cremation statutes are uh
you know Cremation of human remains and
that we call this composting human
remains just say call it what it is uh
you know we don't need to do anything to
confuse the the public
uh into this is something same thing
with alkaline hydrolysis when we talked
about that years ago um is that you know
the terms were resummation and this well
what is it no it's alkaline hydrolysis
okay we can figure out how that process
works that's one of our concerns um and
of course this is a it's funny I've
heard a 4 to 8 to 12we process with
natural organic reduction or with human
composting and we're not clear how long
it actually does take um and as far as
you know to the average person this may
sound like a very basic straightforward
uh biologically sound kind of a holistic
approach you know I mean it kind of you
know might make you feel good and and I
understand that everyone is looking for
something different here and but I don't
think it's nearly that simple we're
concerned that there's a lot more this
is a relatively new process in terms of
human uh disposition of human bodies
been using it in agricultural now for
several decades in for farming animals
which I won't go into that that's not
the scope of this hearing um you know
it's done quite differently there um but
here you know we are worried about the
the soil and the water and any uh
possible air contamination because there
is you know there's a process of
maintaining the right temperatures
there's ventilation in these systems and
then of course what we're dealing with
afterwards you know they refer to it as
a soil but you're going to have the
byproducts of every part of that
decomposition of that body because
that's really what we're talking about
is the decomposition of the body
breaking down our body and back into the
most basic elements those are all going
to be contained in this soil or whatever
this product is that that comes
afterwards uh the long bones as in
cremation will survive this process 3
months is nearly not enough uh and I do
raise the question I believe that DNA is
still held in the bones they found that
in in ancient Graves they're able to
extract DNA from uh individuals who were
buried for hundreds if not thousands of
years uh and uh apparently um anyway
there's other issues like that that
we're we're concerned about um the cost
efficiency doesn't well you know it
isn't the most cost effective thing and
that's up to the individual um mainly
again then the other issue would be uh
soil the transportation of this material
and where it goes right now the bill
would state that it just it can be
placed anywhere with permission of the
landowner well you know that can occur
in New Hampshire
without anyone knowing about it you know
as far as EPA and and the uh Department
of Environmental Services um that you
know we're not talking about a small
amount of material um and then of course
in terms of coming out of the pandemic
as we did we realized that you know what
we need is an effective means of taking
care of our dead and cremation our
crematories were we stayed ahead of
everything during the because we weren't
hit with a uh with a surge like other
states were but we had other states
Massachusetts and Connecticut who are
transporting their dead to New Hampshire
to use our crematories because the
cremation can be done in a Four 3 to
four hour period turn them around they
could bring several individuals up and
pick them up a few days later uh their
crated remains it would be very
effective I mean from a business
perspective this I don't think has a lot
of appeal because of the sheer amount of
time that it takes in order to
accommodate uh an individual and that's
up to the individual uh situation of
course uh they did mention that you know
there seven states I only had six but I
guess there's one more but among them
are Vermont and Massachusetts and then
New York a little further away so we
have two neighboring states who have
approved this but over a year later
there and I spoke with my colleagues in
those uh in Vermont massachusett they're
still working on their regulations after
a year they're still kind of slogging
their way through the regulations so
that tells me there's a there may be
more to this then meets the eye uh and
uh so of course here it's it's a little
confusing too because we're dealing with
two different statutes you know we're
dealing with a new section
325b which I understand you know mimics
if not duplicates the The Cremation
Statute in that it just interchanges
cremation and other similar words for
the natural organic reduction or the
human composting but we can't
interchange these two processes there
very very different incredibly different
particularly when it comes to the
disposition or the scattering of this
material um again as they' said you know
in cremation what remains after
cremation and of course cremation occurs
between 1500 and 18800 degrees it's hot
okay everything uh the container the
body is in whatever clothing whatever
things they're doing those are consumed
first in the process that's gone and
then All That Remains are the the
calcified
large bones that are left and they are
very brittle because of extreme heat
those are broken down in a process and
pulverized into a uniform size so
they'll fit into a container uh an urn
or something similar to that you know I
always joke and say a 2B coffee can if
anyone uses bulk coffee anymore would
accommodate that 5 to six pounds very
easily with this with the material and
we're talking about a cubic yard now I
know most everybody in New Hampshire
probably has a pickup truck or or they
know someone that does so you know but
again we're wondering what you know if
there's anything in this if there's any
environmental issue does this envir
involve either Department of V vital
Department of Environmental Services or
EPA or the uh the
USDA and uh but having the same
requirements for for scattering which is
placed into
289 um would would again would lump the
uh crem cremations with the this organic
this composting soil
um let's see just don't want to repeat
here I've already covered that and of
course you know New Hampshire has an 80%
creation rate which is is rising all the
time and they're always going to be
those who want to have a traditional
burial and uh and they're those who will
donate their body or science or they'll
they will leave they'll be taken to you
know another state for their disposition
I've always said in funeral service that
when people die they go home you know a
few people that die in Florida who came
from New Hampshire they they tend to
come back um so there's other other
issues there I do want to just address
before I close I do want to address a
few of my concerns here that came up you
know we we kind of discussed this last
year with another bill and I just want
to clarify some of this you know I know
we're we're kind of nobody
wants you know nobody wants the funeral
director sitting next to them in the
reception after the the funeral you know
it's like it's like a priest once told
me no one wants the the clergy sitting
with them in a wedding
reception so they've already seen enough
of us but they're misconceptions here
often and we're kind of often made to
look like the bad guy and we tend to try
or the bad woman but we tend to try we
do our best to help the families in in
the State uh we have a real sense of
service and Duty um basically
uh we're very careful in our funeral
service and here in New Hampshire
particularly is that we're not in a
position we don't want to dictate what
any individual should do or shouldn't do
or in this case what the cemeteries
should or shouldn't do you know each
each city or town dictates their own
controls their own cemeteries now we're
not going to tell them what they need to
do there are some cemeteries in New
Hampshire that provide for green
burial and of course there is nothing in
our statute that prohibits green Barrel
alkaline hydrolysis is prohibited
expressly as a result of a legislative
issue a few years ago and but there's
nothing that prohibits green burial or
you doing that that process on your own
property and so forth uh and if the
cemetery offers that space then then you
um and that also there's no requirement
in the state of New Hampshire that you
must be embalmed the only part of the
statute actually it's in the rules that
if you're going to be inomed for the
winter okay between for a spring burial
because many cemeteries particularly the
small ones Clos for the winter you know
we didn't often don't have an open
winter like we do this year uh and many
of these old cemeteries are very small
very hard to negotiate even in the
summertime uh and of course these were
cemeteries were set up back when Graves
were dug by hand and even then they
would hold these bodies over for the
spring Barrel because the ground was
frozen solid bigger cemeteries have the
means to thaw that and do that city of
keing down where I'm from they bury year
round but that's a cemetery issue it's
not for us to dictate what they do or
don't
do what I said last year when we had
another bill talking about EMB bombing
and it was really basically about green
burial and I I'm going to say it again
is that why doesn't someone who's
interested in this or a group of people
get together and form have a establish a
a New Hampshire green burial uh cemetery
and just have it so it's like with our
New Hampshire veterans cemetery there's
that one you know which covers all of
New Hampshire but there could be a
private Cemetery that would offer this
to to individuals who who wanted to have
it rather than trying to get every city
in town you know to forcing them to do
this uh that's not an argument I want to
be in you know I know I come from a
small town of sui and uh and the other
question is that the other thing I want
to clarify is that as far as private
burial I know yes it's permitted in the
state has been for a very long time the
last I did check is that there was is no
longer an acreage requirement the main
it was brought it was pointed out the
only requirement is that the location of
where that body is buried uh is listed
the GPS coordinates are filed with the
registry of deeds so it is on the
document that someone is buried there
you might see that you know there's old
cemeteries all over the place um and
then I'm just going to close up here um
I just had a few more things I wanted to
uh I think I've about covered everything
um but in conclusion I just want to just
say that you know we have our
neighboring states that have approved
this and they're working on their
regulations I would just urge the
committee to maybe was just pause I
would like to pause and see how they
navigate how they navigate this process
you know another year or two or whatever
once they're up and running and see what
I and I want to talk further with my
colleague in New York state you know to
see what what issues they've approached
I I really like to error on the side of
caution I'm a very careful person myself
and I think even more so as a funeral
director um you know and I just want to
evaluate then we can re-evaluate this
and then see if it's something that's
going to be a good fit for um you know
here in the granite state so I want to
thank you for your time and
consideration I went way over my
requested time but I had a lot more uh
here to cover and um I'm welcome Happy
to answer any questions you might
have okay thank
you representative uh
MTI thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question Mr Moren um I have a
couple of questions but I'll start with
the one with the EMB bombing and when
the body is buried after who is
responsible for testing the Le um soil
around where the bodies of embomb emomed
bodies are buried and if there are any
leeching pardon me represent manui that
really isn't relevant to this bill and
we're already over time so if you could
take that offline I'd appreciate
it
okay my okay second question was if the
neighboring states are doing don't we
have the obligation to provide that kind
of a alternative a choices to our
residents now like you said people come
home so to have that option at home
rather than go
outside so won't that be an option to
look at consider
this well to answer answer your second
question um yes people do in general
come home when they die um one of the
advantages if we had it now as we say
with alkaline hydrolysis it specifically
states in the statute and I'm not sure
how exactly that happened well actually
I do and I won't get into that is that
even though it's prohibited here in New
Hampshire we still allow for that
individ ual's body to be shipped to
Maine where there is an alkaline
hydrolysis facility the process can be
done and their little container of
basically their bone residue is returned
to the family so um and I think the same
thing would be with the natural organic
sorry trying to a couple different
places but with natural organic
reduction or human composting if they
was allowed in Vermont and that it would
just be a matter of transporting uh the
body to that facility and uh and to uh
and then it the the the remains would be
returned to the family however that's
done but I think um
yeah I would I would personally prefer
having done this for a while I would
prefer to kind of sort out whatever
questions and issues we think we might
have before we make it statute make it
law because once we do it's a lot harder
to come back here and ask you folks to
change things uh just don't want us to
get into something that we'll regret a
little later uh and I may be totally
wrong I may be totally wrong I'm just I
always air on the side of caution so I
will yield Madam chair thank you else
reprentative
Brown thank you madam chair I tried to
write down uh all of your concerns as
you were going through them he did
provide written
testimony thank you um it seems like a
number of those could be fairly easy
easily handled in Ru making so if you
take out chain of custody which is is
handled through in cremation in rules
right and whether or not you call it no
you call it something different those
aren't huge hurdles in my
estimation if you take those maybe less
drastic pieces out what's the the the
biggest concern that you have about this
if if that makes any sense the question
you elicit a number that I think aren't
maybe as critical as
others no uh thank you representative um
well obviously there there is a
difference there's a variation in how
critical our concerns are um it's it's a
general I guess our con main concern is
that we don't know I think there's more
about this process than we really know
it's all Rel it's all very new um and uh
you know if we have other neighboring
states doing this so that we can get
real information about the issues that
they're finding we can hopefully avoid
those issues and then and I also believe
if if we're going to if we're going to
permit human composting we should go
back and lift the prohibition on
alkaline hydrolysis I mean there no
one's going to agree with everything
believe me and and I understand that and
I appreciate that I do I so I try to
keep my own feelings out of this
entirely uh you know I'm a great
believer as everyone says you know about
offering the people of New Hampshire
choice
and I think we can do that in in several
ways like I said what I explained to the
representative here is that you know we
have neighboring states and once this
process is online then we can see how it
works and and then if we want to adopt
it i' I'd be up here advocating for it
yeah absolutely thank thank
you all right thank you very much for
your testimony thank you madam
Clark
so I'm oh I'm passing around my
testimonial and a green burial flyer for
you to look at and I'll read a shortened
version of what I'm passing out to you
um um my name is Sarah Clark I live in
New Market New Hampshire and I'm a
caregiver in death Dua working to create
a green burial cemetery and I'm in
support of House Bill 1324 and I'll tell
you why through my death duel training I
learned how to provide holistic support
for those in the intense transition of
dying something I had already been doing
in my personal life for years I also
learned about the environmental issues
with cremation and immediately resonated
with the idea of a green burial and I
hope to start a green burial Cemetery
sometime in my life then last summer a
friend who works as a funeral director
in the Sea Coast shared that she
receives many requests for alternative
interment options and is disappointed
she has so little to offer to meet the
wishes of these families since that
fateful conversation an idea was born
and she and I and numerous others have
been working hard to create a green
Barrel Cemetery in the Sea Coast what
started as an exploratory idea has been
solidified into to an incorporated
nonprofit propelled by an astounding
amount of interest and support seemingly
everywhere we turn we have few two
funeral homes that are um committed to
partnering with us based on how much
interest they get from their clients and
we're also in talks with land trusts to
find the right piece of conservation
cemetery I have extras of
those um and and yeah we aim to fit
collaboratively into the existing death
care framework in our area you can see
more about the project on our website
through my green burial Cemetery efforts
I was introduced to representative
lamantine and learned of her work to
further Define green burial terms in our
state statutes I'm so pleased to
lawmaker is paying attention to this
rapidly growing movement and seeks to
expand it even further with natural
organic reduction although I'm not
looking to open a nor facility I'm in
rep of anything that further clarifies
the legality around these alternative
death care options and I would be
delighted to collaborate with any future
North facilities and potentially receive
their excess soil to use to further
conservation efforts on the cemetery
property I'm here today to support these
initiatives because of their gentler
environmental impact and because they
reflect the desires of the many
environmentally conscious individuals in
our community who are asking for more
options
thank you for your attention any
questions other questions representative
Andi thank you madam chair a quick
question are you aware of any other
cultures anywhere else in the world that
is using this process
of
death good
question
um so not not fully I know there's a lot
more flexibility Europe around these
practices um and that's less of a hurdle
and I know that indigenous cultures
really support this type of practice um
but I haven't done a full Deep dive into
the other cultures it's a great idea
thank
you I don't see any other questions so
thank you for your testimony thank you
Bob
Dunn
afterno turn your mic on please there
you go good afternoon Madam chair and
members of the committee I'm Bob Dunn
the director of public policy for the
Roman Catholic dasis of Manchester and
I'm here today on behalf of Bishop Peter
labashi to respectfully register our
opposition to House Bill
1324 and I should say right at the
outset obviously the Catholic church has
teachings on the disposal of human
remains and I am not here to suggest
that you should act in any particular
way because that's what the Catholic
Church teaches all I would like to do is
to uh ask you to consider the principle
that is at the heart not just of
Catholic teaching but it's at the heart
of the secular body politic as well and
that is the principle of the inherent
Dignity of each human
being as you look at the various laws
and rules that deal with the disposal of
human remains it's pretty obvious that
they're uh proceeding from the starting
point that those remains are entitled to
be treated with respect and that's
clearly a consequence of the dignity
that that human being possessed in life
and it also serves as a reminder of and
a reinforcement for
the dignity that human beings possess
and so the way that we treat uh human
bodies is to some degree uh it an it it
has an impact on the way that we treat
living people as well and that's why we
oppose this bill because in our view
natural uh natural organic reduction of
remains uh is a process process that
simply isn't consistent with human
dignity especially in so far as it's
tied to human composting because to
treat the human uh body in a utilitarian
way um is something that reinforces the
principle that H living humans can be
treated in a utilitarian way in our view
uh now I recognize there are going to be
differences of opinion on what is
consistent with human dignity but I
simply ask that
uh in all of the the the discussions
that you're having on this and we've
heard a lot of technical things today
that um as you deliberate you uh answer
for yourselves in your own minds first
of all the question of whether this
process comports with human dignity
thank you madam chair thank you any
questions for Mr dun representative
Schmid thank you madam chair uh
so I I'm I'm
wondering it seems like there's a kind
of a value judgment with regard
um composting com that's I was trying to
remember exactly the word the composting
example but when representative ltin was
testifying she talked about the fact
that once the a certain status is is
reached or state is reached there is no
more DNA there's it's not it's not human
remains anymore it's just
stuff she didn't use that word but I'm
using it if there's no
human no DNA there's nothing left of the
human body right it's just stuff right
well I'd answer that I guess uh by
saying two things first first of all um
I would that was a human body okay so
it's it's something that I think is
inescapably still human remains and if
it's not human remains scientifically it
certainly is I think existentially or
philosophically but secondly um Mr Moren
testified uh that there are still uh
there is still DNA that's uh associated
with the
bones that are in the uh soil as they're
calling it um so uh I I guess I would
just simply respectfully disagree that
this is something that is separated from
that human being that existed
previously okay thank you thank
you thanks very
much m b
yet representative Brown sorry I do have
a question
a question sorry I I thought you saw me
apologies uh thank you for being here
refreshing change of outlook on this
um a person that's buried in a pine box
or a or some other easily decomposable
container that isn't
involed sort of ends up in the same
condition
and do you find a difference in that So
eventually this body that's buried in
the soil decomposes and becomes part of
the soil or it doesn't get
moved
and forgive me for asking this way do
you have a problem with that let me see
if I could be
simple uh do I have a problem with so
there's a is there you see a difference
there between human composting I guess
you're taking the soil elsewhere or just
human composting that happens in the
ground on its own well the I think the
the body that's buried in a traditional
way is not being composted right it's
not being used for the purpose of of
growing other things it it is a given
place thank
you Mel Bennett and Jessica
confusion good afternoon I'm Jessica
Johansson and I am the director of
community engagement for Life Forest
Cemetery in Hillsboro and this is Mel
Bennett she is the co-founder of Life
Forest Creator and co-founder now life
Forest is a nonprofit conservation
Cemetery as I said located in Hillsboro
we provide plots and Memorial trees for
the burial of cremated remains only at
this time life forest was founded on the
need for alternative burial and Memorial
options so we are always in support of
new disposition methods for families to
memorialize their loved
ones it has been life forest's hope and
vision that we would eventually have the
opportunity to provide very options for
those choosing the process of natural
organic reduction or nor so we are
thrilled that a bill authorizing the
natural organic reduction of human
remains is in front of the New Hampshire
State
Legislature
however after reading the bill carefully
we are here to ask you to consider one
important detail which hasn't
significantly been addressed in the bill
and that is the actual definition of the
resulting material of the nor process is
it human remains or or is it a product
if it is a product is it actually soil a
soil additive or is it
compost as a cemetery hosting
conservation land life Forest has an
environmental responsibility to ensure
the safety of any compost or soil that
is brought on to publicly accessible
land over the past year life Forest has
taken the time to research and reach out
to national state and local
environmental agricultural health and
death care agencies for recommendations
of data that should be provided to life
forest in order for the safe and legal
acquisition of any soil or compost
received after the process of
nor This research was done in
preparation for Life Force to be ready
to receive nor upon legalization in
multiple States in our growing
profile according to life Forest
research there are no specific establish
guidelines from any national or State
Environmental or agricultural entities
around the spreading or burial of no
material we have compiled our concerns
along with research citations in the
accompanying document entitled land
application considerations for natural
organic reduction but we would like to
simplify our concerns for you now using
three companies listed in our
research so we have company a they
describe the end result of their natural
organic production process as
soil soil is federally regulated by the
United States Department of Agriculture
the
USDA Company B they describ their end
result of their natural organic
reduction process as
compost compost is regulated by State
Environmental
agencies company C describes the end
result of their natural organic
reduction process as human
remains human remains may be regulated
at the state level by the the Department
of Health Andor office of professional
lure and certification for
example there are many permits required
for and restrictions on the movement of
soil however life Forest research has
not shown the same restrictions on the
moving of
compost whether the final product is
soil compost or soil additive it must
still be a registered product under USDA
guidelines however each of those
designations will come with a different
rule set that needs to be followed this
this is why we believe that the
resulting material of the natural
organic reduction process must be
defined before passing the
legislation thank you very much for that
you hi I'm Mel Bennett I've been
operating a cemetery in New Hampshire
for about four years and went through
the legisl all the process I have um
done some very deep research with the
national level Environmental Protection
Agency as well as the USDA I opened
several inquisitive cases with both
National and as well as the local level
Department of
Agriculture I am so very thankful that
different people have different ways of
healing their heart and we do get a lot
of people who wish for this and I wish
that anybody that wants to heal their
heart in whatever way makes sense to
them I want that to be available to
them but when I made the calls to my
contacts in my ommen at the Department
of Environmental Services there were no
clear answers because any amount of soil
in which you take whether
permanent
or non-permanent placement on land
requires a
permit so when I asked how do I get a
permit for no they said well what is it
so we get you to the right department
and I said it's soil and they said okay
you need to go to the USDA and the USDA
said well you
need even for a small amount a handheld
of soil that's going to go across States
much like
firewood local firewood cannot be
brought across state
lines but firewood that has been
approved sealed and recognized as a
product can you can buy it at Home
Depot but it's because it's been
regulated in a safe
way so my fear is that they're going to
be asking Funeral Directors to become
agricultural experts and then at the end
if we don't have a legal definition of
what it
is there will be a a lot of
responsibility placed on the end result
on where it can go legally and we can't
take it legally because we can't get a
permit for it because the descriptions
are not
clear so this is our concerns do we have
any but I I love the idea I love the
idea that heals Hearts but I just
is thank you that's serious concern any
other
questions all right thank you very much
you're
welcome I take it that someone else who
testify thank you madam chair and thank
you committee for taking my testimony I
understand we're you're running behind
so I apologize um my name is Alison nap
I'm the state representative from
Rockingham M2 stratum and one of the
co-sponsors of this bill um I just
wanted to address a couple of things
that have been mentioned here today one
is that in talking two companies that
are already doing this across the
country um many people choose this for
environmental reasons so the idea that
you would have it done in another state
or have your body transferred to another
state to have this done and transferred
back sort of negates the effect of the
environmental concerns that people are
doing this for so um I respect the idea
that you could do it in another state
but I think many people would want this
available in New Hampshire and and want
the option here um I would also just
remind people that this is enabling
legislation it allows people another
option and for many people this is
something desire they desire when I talk
to people about this bill having been a
co-sponsor um so many people are really
excited about the idea and it's a really
I think it's a really important option
for people to have in the state and
lastly I will say that um we have
reached out to Dees the solid waste
division has said that they would not
regulate compost derived from natural
organic production so um there might be
a question remaining on that that the
committee would would need to
investigate but it has not been our
understanding that it is something that
would have to be regulated in this way
um and we also believe that that could
be addressed in rul making the
disposition well if the statute defines
your product as soil which and looking
at the bill that's what it does then it
needs to fill be regulated as soil if
you're going to declare it as compost
and get a different set of regulations
than we need to to work on the bill okay
so so we're in agreement okay thank you
all right um thank you very much for
your time and I'm happy to take any
questions all right any other
questions all right thank you very
much is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
1324 no thank you very much this will be
going to the sub committee on
rules
and I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill
and oh yes representative Roto will be
dooy
Schmid hi everyone I'm res
representative Jackie groa representing
Rockingham 24 the towns of Greenland and
Ry and I'm here to introduce um
representative Horan's bill um which is
House Bill 1075 and act enabling the
abolishing of daytime daylight savings
time um I believe you all have his
written testimony and I um are there any
other speakers who have signed who have
signed up there are five of them okay
great so I will yield to the other
speakers all right thank
Johnson
good afternoon and thank you for taking
my
testimony
um for several years you might have
remembered a gentleman by the name of Mr
Burnham he lived on Route 13 in
Dunbarton who made national headlines
because he refused to recognize daylight
savings time because he said the cows
don't understand it my crops don't
understand it and neither does my body I
go by the
on I know we've all
experienced waking up that day after the
clocks are
changed um tired and exhausted and
wondering how we're going to make it
through the day and it usually takes us
about a week to get
adjusted as a mom getting our kids
ready during that time is also very
difficult because we have to wake them
up an hour earlier than usual it's been
very
difficult and as a high school teacher
for 26 years I can tell you how much it
is a detriment to students as a teacher
of Juniors and seniors in high school
who are tired they don't get enough
sleep to begin with daylight savings
time does hurt their performance in
class and it usually again takes about a
week two weeks to get
adjusted I think the sun should be the
guide for our bodies it's the natural
natural
um the natural way that our bodies react
I mean I don't know about you but I've
never had to use an alarm clock because
my body knows what time it is so I am in
support of House Bill
1075 and hope you are too thank you for
taking my testimony thank you any
spaling
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Scott spradling I'm
representing the New Hampshire
Association of
broadcasters um this is a uh Repeat
Performance of sorts I think we've had
this conversation around this idea in
multiple sessions before and let me make
it very clear that um uh the the
previous speaker's message absolutely
resonates with the men and women who
work in radio and television every
single day and if it was a matter of our
clock hours in our schedules being set
by the Sun and by the cows we'd be in
great shape but I think it's really
important to understand the reason why
we oppose this bill is because it will
create some very serious uh financial
and scheduling impacts on us radio and
TV works in the clock business many of
our members have radio stations that are
in more than one state the way this bill
and the follow-up Bill are structured it
uh bifurcates all of New England and
sets us apart from the rest of the
region and creates some very real
dramatic and absolutely measurable
fiscal impacts Great Eastern radio
operates along the Connecticut Valley uh
in Claremont in Lebanon up and down the
western part of our great state they
also have stations in Vermont there was
a great deal of simoc casting in New
England radio stations and before anyone
argues well we have already time zones
around the country you are absolutely
right and they were established before
broadcast radio got started so our radio
stations came together after we already
had established time zones not before
this type of an approach this type of a
bill will do immediate damage to an
industry that is already working very
very hard as we watch technological
changes happen around our country I
would respectfully ask that you take a
different approach to something like
this it is admittedly the harder way to
do it but I would hope that our the
sponsor of this bill and the next bill
who have keep offering this proposal
would start collaborating with our
federal delegation and have this
conversation with a 50-state strategy
and not pick a handful of states around
us I think it's also important to note
that at least one of the bills that
you're hearing talks about linking to
Maine and Massachusetts it is our
understanding because the nhab has to
track this with other broadcasters in
other states that these conversations
are not happening elsewhere so you're
wasting your time so I would please ask
that you respect the fact that a
decision like this would have a very
measurable negative effect on the
broadcasters please don't mess with the
clock radio let's go have this
conversation in Washington where it
belongs I'm happy to take
questions thank you are there questions
R Schmidt and the man
py thank you very much Madam chair
welcome Scott thank you representa so uh
we've had bills in the past as you know
it's a it's a an
eternal Timeless shall we say Timeless
subject um uh but but in the past some
of the bills have Incorporated a
provision which says we will we we
really should be in a different time
zone yes sir okay but we will not
representative Schmid this one only says
get rid of just get rid I understand bu
I'm speaking to his point uh we would
only change ours if they change theirs
because New Hampshire is clearly linked
extremely closely to Massachusetts and
also to Maine but much more to
Massachusetts we ain't going anywhere
without Massachusetts moving there too
so would the bill be any less
objectionable if Massachusetts changed
to a time zone that would be better as
far as the son is concerned as the
previous witness was testified sure and
I certainly don't dispute what the
previous witness said and the sort of
the science behind the sunlight
completely understand that but um it
creates problems for our broadcasters
because we have business relationships
not just with Massachusetts and with
Maine but also with Vermont and even
Eastern New York so from the
broadcaster's perspective it just
creates real clock hour fiscal
management problems because we can have
if you change the hour schedule but you
maintain your overall primary schedule
that you have for radio stations you can
have um real problems especially with
night time broadcasting there are
decency and indecency laws that start
with 10 p.m. radio broadcast you can
have as you can imagine if a couple of
states in New England are at 9:00 and a
couple of states of New England are at
10:00 and you've got simoc casting
you're creating some real programming
challenges for local
radio okay thank you very much thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question sure if the you totally abolish
daylight saving time or across the
country then you would be okay with no
problem thank
you all right thank you very much thank
tomier I
need
okay ladies and gentlemen uh Eastern
Standard time is the mean solar time the
75 degree Meridian west of the grenwich
meridian daylight saving time is the
same as Atlantic Standard time which is
the mean solar time of the 60 degrees
west of grenwich
now what does it mean when you say mean
solar time learn something new every day
the Earth rotates in 23 hours 56 minutes
and 4 seconds meanwhile she is moving on
her orbit so when she goes to face the
sun again the same hemisphere takes a
few more minutes to face the Sun from a
new position on her
orbit the exact amount varies during the
year because the orbit is not a circle
it's an ellipse
so sometimes it takes a little more than
24 hours for the same hemisphere to face
the sun again for the sun to Transit the
meridian so sometimes a solar day is
more than 24 hours sometimes it's a few
seconds less and these add up uh during
the months so the average day however is
24 hours what do we mean by mean solar
time well if the sun transits your
Meridian on average 12 hours after your
clock strikes midnight then your clock
is on average solar time the average of
12 hours after midnight that's when the
sun should be crossing the Meridian on
mean solar
time as I said uh Atlantic time is the
mean solar time for 60° West and Eastern
Standard time is the mean solar time for
75 degrees west and the Legislative
Office B building in which we are
sitting is 71.5 4 degrees west a lot
closer to 75 than to 60 so it makes
sense for New Hampshire to be in the
Standard time zone and not the Atlantic
time zone I want to debunk the myth here
with these Maps the myth that New
Hampshire belongs in the Atlantic time
zone you can see in the lower map there
the the map of the time zone it kind of
looks like G it's so far east maybe it
belongs in the the Atlantic time zone
but no uh it's because the western
boundary is so far west that it just
kind of creates that illusion in a lot
of people's minds take a look at
Michigan Northern Michigan is on the
most of it is on Eastern
time the boundary actually belongs 82
and a half degrees west and most of
Michigan belongs in central time so just
as Maine would be split by a time zone
line at 67 and a half Washington County
Maine would be split and the line would
go through Western New
Brunswick most of New England almost all
of New England belongs on Eastern time
and why not just draw the line that so
that all of Michigan would be in the
central time zone people are led to
think that New Hampshire is so far east
that it belongs in Atlantic time because
of the illusion because Michigan is
mostly on Eastern Time so why don't they
just draw the boundary lines halfway
between the meridians oh sure let's see
now 75 degrees west 90 degre West
halfway between is 82 and 1 half degrees
west right smack dab through the city of
Tampa Florida H and it gets
better 90° West 105 degrees West let's
go halfway in between 97 and2 degre west
right smack through the middle of the
heart of downtown Oklahoma City missing
the state capital building by a couple
of blocks imagine having a time zone
boundary through conquered missing the
state house by a couple of blocks lots
of fun so it makes sense to adjust the
boundaries a little bit to follow county
lines and international borders for
convenience but uh that's would be a
difference between maybe uh 28 minutes
slow or 32 minutes fast but here we have
a situation where we have a choice
between being 13 minutes and 51 seconds
slow behind local mean solar time of
this building or 46 minutes and 9
seconds fast by being on daylight saving
time so for this reason while we should
discontinue the changing of clocks we
also need to select uh Eastern Standard
Time as the standard and not permanent
daylight saving time which by the way is
singular contrary to what some people
test ifying here today have done it's uh
not daylight savings time it's daylight
saving time take a look at the text of
the bill there okay
so uh as Benjamin Franklin said facts
are stubborn John Adams excuse me said
facts are stubborn things and whatever
may be our wishes our inclinations or
the dictates of our passions they cannot
evidence thank
you Karen
Johnson
been
C thank you madam chairperson committee
um I am here um in support of HB
1075 um and oppose HB
1679 for permanent daylight savings time
um my name is Dr Karen Johnson I'm a
sleep physician a neurologist I actually
live in Springfield Massachusetts but I
have a family in New Hampshire my family
owns land in New Hampshire I come up
here for skiing and hiking and um
Recreation um and so I really strongly
urge you to support um permanent
Standard Time and age 1075 um for three
main reasons permanent Standard Time as
we just heard is the more naturally
aligned time time and more naturally
aligned um suntime is best for our sleep
our circadian rhythms which stay aligned
with the sun no matter what time we set
on our watches and our phones and sleep
circadian rhythms is really the pillar
of not only physical health um but
mental health as well as our cognitive
um function which as a neurologist um I
think is of of great importance um as we
heard before um when we're on the wrong
time it affects um you know our ability
to get up our ability to get our kids to
school our ability for our kids to do
well in school um and that affects um
our families um it affects our children
adolescents have a natural delay in
their rhythms so they actually have the
highest impact from being on daylight
savings time um leading to the most
impacts and it's also bad for our
overall Workforce most um jobs start um
before 8:00 a.m. and those people are
more likely to lose sleep um even though
a lot of people if you ask them um you
know how do you want to end time change
most people about 60 to 70% of Americans
say we we hate the clock Change we want
to end it and and people aren't really
sure of what which way to go um a lot of
people default to Daylight Savings time
because they think of Summer and they
think daylight savings time will bring
Endless Summer daylight savings time
does not add any hours to the day it
just shifts the timing of that sun later
and um the maps I showed you show what
effect it has on the mornings so in New
Hampshire there would be 60 to 70 days
with the sun rising after 8:00 a.m. it
would be as late as about 8:20 um in the
morning in New Hampshire those dark
mornings um again make it harder to get
up to get going there's more icy roads
to drive on there's kids standing at
their bus stops back in 1974 the last
time we tried permanent Daylight Savings
Time one of the reasons it was so
unpopular were kids dying at their bus
stops um and again you're basically
telling people get up um go to work an
hour earlier then your body um is
ready in terms of some of the health
impacts a lot of people think the only
problem is when we make that switch and
there are more heart attacks more
Strokes more car accidents that happen
especially in the spring after we go to
Daylight Savings time but what what a
lot of people don't realize is our
bodies don't adjust within a week or two
our bodies stay Al IGN to the um natural
Sun time and so that misalignment causes
us to lose sleep throughout the whole
period of daylight savings time um
places that have later sunrises and
sunsets have higher rates of obesity
higher rates of cancer have higher rates
of fatal car crashes higher rates of
seasonal depression higher rates of
suicide these have been proven with
studies that have separated the effect
of what is sort of the length of the day
so so some of these things get better in
summer so you think oh Daylight Savings
Time must be better but when you
separate that length of the day effect
from the time we set our clock effect we
know that it's those later clock times
that are causing that circadian
disruption and causing um these worst
outcomes um I want to um talk about uh
it was mentioned with the radios um we
do think that a national option would be
best
so permanent Standard time is already
federally preapproved so any state can
just say we want to go on Standard time
and it can happen immediately and that
is why for the most part we do endorse
packed bills to avoid the economic and
radio and other issues that we heard
before um we have a growing number of
states introducing Standard Time bills
some are immediate um but for example
Massachusetts is saying we would only go
forward if New Hampshire Rhode Island um
Connecticut and uh who am I forgetting
um uh and Rhode Island would um adopt it
too Connecticut's Bill is saying you
know we will only do it if Massachusetts
and New York will only do it so you get
these ever increasing packs where it
won't actually happen um unless again a
bous region um goes forward or more
importantly we hope that it just signals
the federal government to go forward um
we really need to have these State bills
pass to show the federal government that
there's interest in standard time
because the Assumption right now um
because some Daylight Savings Time bills
have passed before we got out there
saying the harms of this that that is
what people want we need to tell people
in the F girl amendment that no we are
interested in um having Standard time so
if you want to expand the P you know the
states that are listed on this bill I
think that could be reason reasonable if
you want to make sure that vermonts in
there and other ones but just the way
the other states are having with their
bills um it will be this sort of ever
growing pact um you know overall again
the reason we made time zones was to
align economic interests trains going
across um and it was called Standard
time because the sun was overhead at
noon at the Meridian at the midpoint of
the time zone this is the more natural
time um daylight savings time was Broad
in first in World War II um and then in
1974 um as a way to try to get people to
go to work an hour earlier um and to
save energy they never found that they
saved energy um and in fact more recent
studies Indiana that used to be mostly
on Standard Time found that when they
ended Standard time there was actually a
1% increase um in energy cost related to
increase Heating and Cooling bills so a
lot of the more recent um data shows
that daylight savings time is actually
um causes an increase in energy other
data out of Indiana showed that students
do worse um on standardized tests um
when uh they were in even partial
daylight savings time than when they um
were on Standard Time so the choice of
time is really important affects all our
lives we want to end the time change but
we need to do it the right way with
permanent Standard Time um I'm here on
behalf of the Coalition of permanent
Standard time which is um made up of the
American um Academy of sleep medicine
the Sleep research Society the society
for research on biological diseases um
the national sleep foundation and Stave
Standard Time um the American Academy of
Neurology also has endorsed it the
American thoracic Society um the
American Medical Association um other uh
teachers groups like the parent teacher
Association has endorsed it some
religious groups have endorsed permanent
Standard time because of the way it
affects prayer times so there's a lot of
um support report um for a permanent
Standard time and we hope you will
consider this
Bill thank you are there any
subte I'm not sure I don't not entirely
don't not sure it needs subcommittee but
thank
you exactly
all right it thank you all right is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
elier I won't need to debunk the idea
that the argument that the people are
more habituated to Daylight Saving Time
first of all if we're habituated to
Daylight Saving Time when are we going
to break that bad half habit if not now
and secondly the only reason that we're
habituated toward daylight saving time
is because we've been forced to if
you're told to bring your kids to school
by 7:30 they better get there by 6:30
when they're pretending it's 7:30 or
you're going to get in trouble uh that's
what daylight saving time is it's
pretending it's an hour later than it
really is and if you have to be in court
by 9:00 a.m. you better be there at 8:00
a.m. when they're pretending it's 9:00
a.m. or you're going to jail so it's
only because we've been for
uh to be habituated to Daylight Saving
Time that so uh that's I'm just uh
finish with that thank you is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
1075 all right not seeing anybody I'm
going to close the hearing and open the
hearing on House Bill 1679 and call
Representative
Ella
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name for the record is
representative Josh Oella from Fremont
Danville and
Brentwood and I'm here today to
introduce HB
1679 um relative to changing to
Atlantic time and you um
in in um my five years in this
legislature I've brought this this bill
multiple times and much of the um stuff
I've talked about about the the changing
of the times has already been said about
its detrimental
effects however um in the last hearing
and in years prior so I uh did not print
out the voluminous documentation on that
um so it seems like today there's um uh
two different approaches what both are
in agreement that switching the the
times are are uh not beneficial both
healthwise economic wise for a host of
reasons um and this method of uh
changing to Atlantic Atlantic Standard
time is the
uh preferred method uh by many people um
by their advocacy for not dislike for uh
super early
uh uh sunsets and and getting off of
work essentially in the dark and um I
would point you to the uh 2017 special
Commission on the Commonwealth uh time
zone that I had previously uh given in
years past to this committee but can be
uh can be found
online uh that talks about uh this this
issue and the benefits of it in in
relation to the uh
Northeast and I bring this uh and I am
in agreement obviously that that uh the
Senate at the federal level I'm I'm
happy what they did as far as passing um
a bill that would have allowed uh
daylight savings time all year round uh
Senate Bill
1623 um in 2022 in Congress but uh that
bill was uh failed in in the um house it
wasn't acted upon and so there is still
an effort in the Northeast by many of
the states ongoing to move to Daylight
Savings Time or uh all year round or uh
Atlantic's time zone there is no um
other state considering doing Standard
time all year round in the Northeast um
New Hampshire uh Massachusetts currently
has a bill
3050 that is doing Atlantic time zone
all year
round uh Connecticut is doing at uh
proposing a bill for Atlantic time zone
all year
uh Vermont is proposing daylight savings
time all year
round uh and New York is proposing
daylight savings time all year
round those all have the same net effect
of being on the exact same time and it's
not the Eastern Standard time
zone um and so if you were to um be uh
trying to go so with the the rest of the
uh states in the region they have
unanimously decided that doing either
daylight savings time all year round if
the federal government allows that or Mo
requesting to move to Atlantic time
zone uh from the Secretary of
Transportation those are the methods uh
that that the states have been ProMag
gating in the legislature um currently
and
so my my bill this time is a little bit
more complicated than in years past and
one of the reasons for that is um the
the piece of paper that I passed around
is uh the document from the Department
of Transportation uh the US Department
of Transportation on um kind of how they
decide whether or not you're allowed to
move to a different time zone or not and
some of the things that they require is
information about um where do businesses
get their supplies and where do they
ship their goods and products and and
and even the media uh broadcast where
those come from and uh
so the the intro the bill as introduced
would essentially have a commission of
all those states that agree um come
together form together and um compile
that information for the and submit that
to the Secretary of Transportation um so
so that it's a unified message so that
we can get approved for the moving of
the time zone um so that is the why the
bill is a little bit longer than than
before other states just say we're just
going to move um or you know once once
the other other states adopt it but in
fact you have to request that
information from the uh or that that
change from the the the Secretary of
Transportation and this bill helps uh
you prepare the information to go to
there so that it can get approved so I'm
Bic years ago many years ago I guess my
company sent me to California for a
month sorry and uh all the TV shows we
traditionally thought of as evening TV
shows right were all on in the late
afternoon I
guess I guess that was their cow Towing
to New York maybe or the East
Coast because they were all the evening
shows but late
afternoon uh do we give a damn what
Massachusetts and Main think let's just
do it thank you for the question um from
California's perspective I'm sure they
consider them afternoon shows and you
and uh that you're just watching them at
the wrong time um but uh I I do think
that the uh I do agree that it would be
beneficial to move however there is um
significant uh
economic
um ties between New Hampshire and
Massachusetts and the and and Maine and
so for the people that that live in New
Hampshire and work in those uh States I
think it's a little bit different than
the the Arizona example where most uh
that there are isn't really big cities
right on the the border that would be
majorly affected um as as much as
essentially our a significant portion of
our
population uh going across state lines
for for work and stuff like that so I do
I do agree that there is um that there
is some benefit of going as as a group
but I'm not opposed to just going going
on our own but I don't I don't work in
Massachusetts so I wouldn't be
negatively affected like some other
people so I
followup would we then say that
Hampshire is the tail being wagged by
the
dog I'm not sure how to respond to that
I will than you never thank
you representative
Brown thank you madam
chair based on some of the handouts and
already
there's it is said that your circadian
rhythm doesn't change if I'm
understanding it correctly and there's a
certain time frame that's better for
that so
let's say you moved to
California your circadian
rhythm stays the way it was as a New
Hampshire
relate so being being that question if
we change the time zone here and someone
moves how does that help them or how
does it not help them thank you thank
you for the question that makes the
slightest bit of sense um I think I
think thank you for the question but um
um as someone that was born in
California and I moved here I do uh
think your uh the circadium rhythm is
based on the sunlight and so you have
different sunlight here and so you're
over a certain amount of time of living
in New Hampshire your circum Rhythm
would would reflect the sunlight that
you're getting here you're not no longer
getting the sunlight in California right
so your cirium Rhythm would slowly over
um overtime shift to reflect that uh new
place that you're living and so uh that
is kind of what a lot of people talk
about is like jet lag and stuff like
that is your circadian rhythm kind of
adjusting again um to that other other
time
zone um so I think that hopefully that
answers your question that's thank you
other questions all right I don't see
any other questions thank you for your
testimony thank you is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill
yes I just do want to clarify
please I do just want to uh clarify
where the bills stand there are both um
permanent daylight savings time which
are couched as Atlantic Standard Time
the reason they're doing that is they're
trying to get around the Federal
prohibition against Daylight Savings
Time by changing the time zone rather
than changing to the the the whether
you're on Standard time or daylight
savings time um but there are bills in
um Massachusetts in um Vermont and in
New Hampshire for both directions right
now um last year they haven't been
reintroduced in 2024 there were
Connecticut bills so there are a lot of
bills in our area Maine currently has a
study that is studying it so there's a
lot of active bills um and they're
equally as much for standard time in
Massachusetts we actually have more
sponsors for the Standard Time bill then
the daylight savings time Bill in the
federal government they tried to sneak
the um bill past uh the the how they
brought up for emergency vote uh sort of
last minute vote um and it did pass the
Senate but was not taken up by the house
um there was actually less sponsors that
signed on for the 2023 version of the
bill than the 2022 version bill so we
are seeing the movement towards more and
more Standard Time bills less support
for Daylight Savings Time bills last
year no Daylight Savings Time bills
passed any states um for the first time
in a few years because of the increasing
education um that it is less aligned
with our Natural Body thank you thank
you all right anyone else all right I'm
closing the hearing on House Bill
and we're going on to the subcommittee
bill House Bill
1689 relative to the use of person
identifying information by state
agencies but first we're going to take a
five minute break we are going to take a
five minute
you
it's always nice that the
uh that the Standard Time folks are
opposed to the daylight this was going
to subit I didn't mean to say no but at
the same time I'm think oh my why do we
need to talk about this some
more you're not on subte you're
done if you're not on the subcommittee
forward
we going to stop at 4:30 because that
way we don't have to have extra
security um clearance because as the
building closes at
4:30 which but we should have plenty of
hopefully you're going to be stuck here
California
I'm going to start the subcommittee
meeting um the way that I'd like to have
this
subcommittee um go today is that we have
some um people here from the Secretary
of State's office who are going to talk
about the um safety and the Privacy meas
measures that they take and the
information that they need and then
perhaps um Mr Kirk you might speak after
them and then we can discuss the HHS
impact of financial impacts on HHS
separately does that seem like a good
plan to
everyone okay so would um the
individuals from the Secretary of
us
thank
you um I'm Kristen kenniston registar of
Vital Records and this is Chris Wilder
agent my name is Christopher Wilder I am
the
yes uh so I did submit and I'm hoping
you reive a copy of them um a list of
statutes that I had identified as we
could have some um we would need
clarification on and I gave that
testimony the other day where um we need
to make sure that we're very clearly
handling this bill if it passes I need
to make sure that we can still issue
certified copies to other um
governmental agencies outside of just
DHHS because we do deal a lot with um
Social
Security Department of Justice um
Department of Corrections we have anou
with um so I'm I'm basically here to
answer any questions you have as far as
um how we handle our
information there seems to be a lot of
concern about the Privacy issue so how
is it that this is maintained and how is
it audited so that we know that it's um
always up to date so when information is
input into our neverin database and our
never database is um the new Hampshire
Vital Records Information Network it's
it's a just a what's the word I'm
looking for acronym thank you for what
that stands for that's our database that
holds all of our Vital Records right now
so it gets entered in and anybody who
accesses it is um a user that signs up
and they get clearance depending on what
their role is we assign them certain
access levels within that system it's
very very strict so when you start
getting to the point that we're
involving health statistics that are
being collected as part a vital record
there's only a handful of us that
actually can see it within the division
of Vital Records um there was a bill
that I testified on this morning and I
just make a clarifying point that when
they say the Secretary of State's office
has access to this they're actually
referring to my division and only those
of us with high admin levels at the at
the division um as far as access to
Vital Records the state of New Hampshire
all V vital records are closed so you
can't just go in and ask for a copy of
anybody's record you actually have to
have what's called a direct and tangible
interest in the record in order to
obtain it right now um DHHS is
considered having a direct and tangible
interest in our Vital Records and
statistics just based off of their work
in our memorandum of understanding that
we have in place um so this bill we need
to clarify how that would affect their
direct and tangible interest if it's
only to the identifying information
that's being collected with the health
statistics or if I'm not allowed to give
them um certified copies of Records like
what does that look like for us at the
division anyone on the committee have
any
questions this is sort of along the same
lines um when I was listening to the
testimony the other day I I have to ask
you do you think there's anything
broken that that was trying to be fixed
from an administrative standpoint from
an administrative standpoint I've not
had any concerns uh we're very careful
with the data that we're giving
out thank you it's one of our top
priorities um we actually even take hipa
training even though we're not required
to because we're not hipa entities we go
beyond
and are there policies that you know how
do you maintain the confidentiality I
mean how is this communicated within
your organization it's all within the
statutes and for anybody who's in house
um we work very closely together with
training so any of the division of idal
Records users um it's all in training we
can't give this information now you
can't just go in and start looking
things up because you feel like looking
things up that's not how this works it's
got to be initiated for a specific
purpose and and your role only allows
you a certain um Viewpoint of what you
can see within the record itself the
other users like for example your your
town clerk's users or Funeral Directors
whoever it is that can have access when
they sign up to gain access there's a
very strict list of what you can and
cannot do this is your activity within
the system is being monitored um you and
limited so depending on what the role is
they can only see so
much thank you Mr Wilder can you explain
to the commit subcommittee your invol
your work in in this role um I have
worked for the division now for six
years first five years was as an
independent
consultant and the last year plus has
been as an actual full-time employee um
initially starting out as a mortality
surveillance agent I was brought on to
register train and educate both Funeral
Directors doctors nurses hospitals
funeral homes Etc on the use of the
system um this last year has been a
little bit more broadened in scope but I
still handle all of the registrations
for or most of the registrations for new
users applying for application the
vetting of those applicants and the
registration process of them um I also
work closely with our team to help
um when we do any redesigns of any of
our modules and what needs to be changed
within the modules um I troubleshoot
problems from calls that come in uh so
division Ro
Schmid thank you madam chair so as you
know we've been in this trench
before uh and and and we've had
considerable problems with conflicting
interests there are the interests of
citizens in
privacy um but there are also certain
medical aspects in which uh
identification
of children with early health problems
where immediate treatment is vital for
these children
represent this is the Secretary of
State's office I think the question that
you want to ask is for HHS so can you
just wait for that well but I have to
frame it to to these people as well
because they're the ones that that are
in control of the creation uh the usage
and the
maintenance uh of the record system um
and to the degree that they are uh doing
something which is helping the one side
and hurting the other side go ahead so
uh if you're dealing with especially
with a a a newborn okay you have to know
who the parent is and you have to be
able to identify the medical emergency
that arises in some cases I think it's a
relatively small number of uh percentage
but you have children who must be
treated in very short order or they are
going to be uh lifelong sufferers from
the some some kind of an illness uh that
that could have been prevented had they
been treated immediately and if they're
not they they're going to suffer a
lifelong disability and we had people
the last time around talking about and I
met some of the parents who were here
with their children who had not been
recognized early enough because Med
medical science was not there yet and
therefore they were not
treated um and so that's one one of the
things I'm very concerned about and is
there is there a way of of having a
record package if you will that
initially has all the data in terms of
name address contact information and so
forth tying mother and child together
and if that child is one of those that
needs immediate treatment that they're
going to get
it but at some point the form can be
pulled apart so that some of the crucial
information that is needed at the
beginning uh serves that purpose and
then when the form is pulled apart in my
concept pulled apart then it's no longer
a is not connected to be anymore and you
and the that person's privacy and so
forth is there protected but you you get
the medical benefit is there some way
that your forms are currently designed
or could be designed uh to to to achieve
what I've been talking about because
you're the ones that can that well to
some degree the forms are under your
control but I think some of the forms
are also generated and dictated by the
federal government right it's federal
law so you C you can't disregard that
without getting in considerable
difficulty from that respect so can you
speak to that um I will try to answer
your question on that so uh the way the
form is designed does follow the
National Standard for what um the
federal government is saying we should
be collecting for information that is
both on the demographic piece that we're
collecting to create the birth
certificate itself and also on the
statistical piece that is used for
public health um currently the form has
it all collected together and it is put
into our Nan database together so when
it goes to DHHS right now it is going as
one de data set it's not being separated
out they're separating out their data on
their end for anybody who has access to
it which they can speak to that there's
very similarly structured to us where
they have um access granted only certain
people and then again we're focusing on
data quality and on the birth
certificate that all facilitates the the
the ability to perform these vital
medical uh testing and and potentially
treatment operation
where they are needed uh at at at the
time they are needed that correct that
is well that's something you probably
want to ask I will ask them we're going
to have this handled by HHS I'd like to
have thank you very much I'd like um and
Mr Kirk if you could kindly come forth
and express your concerns with this
legislation or the passage of this
legislation and representative Bolton if
too did did Mr Kirk hear
me
y
right actually um I was going to defer U
uh
honorable Kirk but I've got a question
just about the um the way this bill is
going to be handled in committee I know
it's an early Bill and um um I guess
some of the Committees are looking at
February 15th before they have to get
the bills out or for your information
the deadline for this committee to
report out the bill is February 15th
okay I have scheduled an executive
session for February 7th which will
allow us time to get an amendment if or
some or you know we we'll get most of
our bills out then we could delay a
little bit but okay we're up against a
deadline thank you thank you
go
ahead thank you madam chairman for uh
allowing me to speak
um this bill is is one of many which
have been and will be introduced over
the next few years in order to bring the
state into compliance with the
Constitutional privacy Amendment which
passed in
2018 um that Amendment basically um
requires or forbids the state agencies
or the state to have access to
personally identifiable information
except under uh extraordinary
circumstances this
bill primarily is saying that with
respect to certain Vital Records um
statistical data about them will go to
the Departments but no personal
information but personal information
will be retained by uh the Secretary of
State's office vital records and will
not be shared this bill doesn't address
the issue of whether the state
Department's acquisition of that
information is constitutional or not
that's a separate question for another
day the question this bill addresses is
information sharing what information
that agency that one agency Vital
Records gets uh can be shared with other
agencies in the state where its
personally identifiable information is
involved if it's plain statistical
information this bill really doesn't
relate to that it just bars the
transmission of personally identifiable
information from Vital Records to others
um the registar and she just
testified uh wrote a I thought rather
compelling brief that explained how
complex this area is and how
intertwined the various sections of
current law is and how some of the
provisions of this Bill left unanswered
questions for her as to how she was to
administer the law should this bill pass
and whether or not there were some
conflicts between what this bill was
doing and what current law
was
um because it's such a complex area uh I
know that if I were sitting on this
subcommittee I would not be able to
address it in any reasonable time frame
so I'd like to offer a suggestion that
works with the Chairman's time frame and
might be a a reasonable way to get the
best possible result in the shortest
period of
time
um before I do that I just like to make
one OBS one General observation which
folks need I hope will keep in
mind a lot of the testimony on privacy
bills that I've heard today 484 in the
Senate and this bill when it was
originally uh coming before the
committee
um focused a lot on how how well state
agencies did in protecting personal
information from people who weren't
supposed to have access to it that's not
what this bill is
about the real question is what
information should this personal
information should the state be able to
get and keep in the first
place not a question of what they do
with the information when they get it
it's a question of what personally
identifiable information under the
Constitutional Amendment the state is
allowed
get this bill says in effect whatever
Vital Records can get it can't share
personally identifiable part the
statistical part it can share so here's
my suggestion to to try to work this
out establish a working group um headed
by with the sponsor and and two members
from this committee a Republican and a
Democrat to work with the registar and
produce by next what's today Wednesday
by next Wednesday a working draft it
would largely be written by the
registar with the legislators involved
making sure that her draft complied with
the principles that I'm going to suggest
be
incorporated if if that approach were
followed it would be possible for the
committee to be assured that whatever
came out uh met whatever standards it
had um without themselves becoming
expert in the minutia of these very
complicated intertwined
sections the principles that I would um
suggest guide this group and indeed if
you don't establish this group guide the
subcommittee is that number one a no um
personally
identifiable
information that vital records has
should be shared with any other state
agency Health and Human
Services um Corrections the retirement
system
um number two B that no
personally that's hospitals let's leave
that aside um third that informed
consent be required if and when Health
and Human Services or any other
department is to access personally
identifiable information in other words
the person involved needs to agree yes
the state may have this information
personally identifiable information
about
C that any access to personally
identifiable information by a state
department is on a caseby Case basis in
other words they don't get the whole
data set but they get whatever they need
in a particular case to deal with a
particular individual again with that
individual's
consent
um finally an
observation um this bill has financial
implications and it's an FN uh
the department has in other cases and
I'm sure they would he explain why we
will lose all sorts of federal revenue
if this bill goes forward um my
suggestion to the committee is that to
focus on the PRI the policy aspects of
this and leave the questions of finances
and loss of federal revenue to the
finance committee this is an FN bill and
I suspect the finance committee will
take it division 3 will look at this and
get information not just from Health and
Human Service serves our department but
from the federal departments to confirm
in fact if there will be a loss of
Revenue if certain information that
traditionally has been passed on will
will not be passed on in the future so
those three principles would enable this
working group to come up with a bill
which then the committee as a policy
matter could make an informed decision
on thank you madam
chairman you your time and thank you for
your um your breakdown on on your um
Kirk so Neil have you provided the
details of the the points that you were
just enunciating you already provided
that inwriting
to uh the appropriate
departments no this is the very first
opportunity I've had to do this and I
thought it's not my position to do that
it's a question for the subcommittee as
to what they want to do my proposal is
just a
suggestion and it involves two things
one how do we get how do you folks get
past a very complicated area in a very
short period of time and B what
principles what policy directives do you
want to give the folks who are going to
do this work I suggested the three that
I would give them but obviously you
folks could give them those others
whatever you wanted to do so nope
representative Schmidt I have not spoken
to anyone except this committee and
representative Bolton about this I I
took diligent notes because I think it's
very important obviously your years of
experience should not be you know left
aside for foolishness like the fact that
you're no longer in office uh you you're
still very much up on all these issues
and I I'd like to make sure that we that
we make this this proposed solution as
per perfect as possible even if we don't
get it to perfect I share your concern
thank
you thank you um I'd like to call Trish
Chile to the uh the
table and what I've asked um AJ chess to
do is to review with the
subcommittee the
um
invol the loss the financial loss of
funding per
the per the subgroup of people that are
involved I thought it would be helpful
that representative per Kirk said this
is going to go to finance we don't
really need to go into great detail on
the finance in my opinion but your
committee right I I'm sorry I we're
happy to do whatever the committee would
like us to do well if you can do it in
the next like 10 minutes that would be
great great um so again thank you so
much for having me my name is Patricia
Tilly I am an associate commissioner at
the Department of Health and Human
Services and I had the pleasure of
speaking with you earlier about this
bill um we all understand um that 1689
has far-reaching consequences impacting
needed Health Services economic supports
and fraud prevention for New Hampshire
residents understandably there was a
tsunami of information the last time
that we were here and at the direction
of the committee we are happy to walk
through quickly several examples where
the department uses our direct and
tangible interest to assist New
Hampshire residents and the financial
impact if those Services were not
available we will do that quickly you
can you know get the gong show U hook on
us as as you would like um we also want
to just I want to suggest right in the
beginning that we're all here to provide
input on this policy discussion about
balancing New Hampshire's intrinsic
belief in privacy with the need of
government's efficient effective and
necessary flow of information to provide
those Essential Health and Social
Services for New Hampshire's infants and
mothers in particular for this dead this
is a balance um you know I always Le
learn from former representative Kirk he
has kept me on the straight and narrow
for many years but I know that this
committee is going to be considering
these things so there are four broad
areas for us to consider there's the
public health aspects of what it would
mean for the Department of Health and
Human Services to not have both um the
identifier the name of the individual as
well as the medical information that we
learned is on the back end of the the
birth certificate we need to talk about
the legitimate investigations of fraud
or abuse of public surfaces um if we
cannot look up and and determine if an
individual is a mother a father or a
child of a per certain person we're
going to we know that there's going to
be federal funds that are lost we can do
that here we can talk about that in
finance committee as well that also
affects the efficiency and accessibility
of services available to Residents and
as Miss kenniston noted there are a
number of statutes with which this bill
conflicts it sounds like she's done a
phenomenal job of of drafting those out
we won't need to um add anything to that
so and the last thing that I would just
sort of put out in the ether is there
are some of the program as we talk May
address or may not in the interest of
time time that there's also
interjurisdictional
issues um as you know all 50 states have
adopted the same type of data that get
collected in the same way 49 states do
it through their Departments of Health
one state New Hampshire does it through
their um through their division of Vital
Records which is not in the Department
of Health regardless the information is
very important to be able to be
exchanged when we know that you know 10%
of New Hampshire residents give birth in
New in a different state and roughly 10%
% of people who give birth in New
Hampshire who would be respond would
need um live in a different state so I
am going to um ask some folks to come up
here we're going to start with even
though representative um Kirk noted that
security is not an issue I actually
think it's important to ground Us in the
fact that the data is secure I also
think that they can talk a little bit
about the financial implication of
upending every single system that we
have in the Department of Health and
Human Services so we're going to start
with them then we're going to talk about
how we do the statistics and how we use
maternal and Child Health Data and then
to the degree that you're interested we
can go through all of the economic
supports child support estate recovery
tan up snap or just do a few we have
experts in newborn screening um
representative Schmidt in the room we
have other experts we have lawyers we
have analysts all here to answer the
questions you have so I'm talking fast
so we can give time to Dave weers and to
come up and um start us
off
so did commissioner did you hear
anything from representative Kirk um in
his initial re go round that uh that
troubled you with regard to
workability so uh we are troubled with
the notion that the Department of Health
and Human Services would no longer have
the direct intangible interest in
identifiable information we know that
this is a place that we have a uh a an
honest disagreement on and it's a place
where as the the legislature you're
going to have to make a decision moving
forward we are always happy to spend
some time thinking about the ways that
we can make this better but there is
some fundamental um impasses that we
might not be able to get around but
there are also probably other areas for
you um Madam chair members of the
committee thank you for having me here
my name is David weeders um the
information Services director for
DHHS and I'd like to start with once we
receive the data in order to perform
Services all the different services that
you've heard um associate commissioner
Trisha Tilly speak to we have to ingest
it and move it through our very robust
data governance and data security and
privacy practices and so we take this
very seriously but as part of doing that
we integrate with a lot of different
systems each of those systems are under
contract with different vendors and
those contracts follow our security and
privacy or privacy and security
practices to ensure that they're hippot
trained that they're following all state
and federal laws and that they're
following our specific data governance
practices for how data is managed
throughout the department so we when
earlier in the discussion I think
represent Schmidt you asked about
policies for Secretary State and how
they managed and they had a number of
laws that govern how they manage the
data we have the same laws but then on
top of that just like they have with
HIPPA training we also because we
receive all that information into what
we call an Enterprise data warehouse we
have very specific policies as how that
is managed so we have confidentiality
and business use agreements for every
individual regardless if they're a state
employee or a contractor that has to be
signed in order to control what they are
allowed to do and what the ramification
ations are if they do not manage the
data properly we also have asset use
agreements on how they manage our assets
how they utilize assets that we give to
them we have our data classification
policy in this case um we have multiple
levels um this is the highest level so
Vital Records data is the highest level
it's regulated and Regulatory and
compliance data so it's marked in our
Data Systems as the most stringent
access what that means is we follow
minimal use and so minimal use really
comes to if you're in child support you
need specific fields in order to move
forward with the child support services
you might not need the health related
data that public health needs and in
economic stability you also need
specific Fields I'm not going to go into
the details of the fields because you
probably get pretty bored of all the
tables and all the other components
associated with that but you don't need
the entire record set so we manage that
through our Enterprise statea warehouse
and Enterprise business intelligence Pro
system and the data governance processes
that we have within that data governance
we have data stewards and so what what
we did did on purpose we identified data
storage within every program area that
is responsible for understanding the
laws governing the data including our
state constitutional rights regarding
privacy as well as the best practices on
how to secure that data so once you know
what data you're getting and the privacy
laws regarding it now you have to make
sure you're securing that information so
that's what the data Steward is supposed
to do and they are trained through
multiple different training we have a
training policy that requires everyone
to go through that training and then
they tell our our my division or Bureau
who can have access and to what What
fields and data that they can have
access to I'm trying to express that
specifically so you understand that we
don't just give 3,000 people in DHHS
access to the data it's actually 338
people and out out of those 338 people
not all of them have access to the
entire data set and so it's really it
gets even smaller and smaller as it goes
forward so the the chances of um misuse
is very small and the chances of
actually providing care and better
Client Services is very high because
we're sharing this
information we have other policies that
I won't go into but I'm certainly here
to address some of that if you have any
questions specifically regarding
security and privacy as it relates to
the data the other component is because
of the integration with some of our
systems and you might have heard terms
like new heights which is our integrated
eligibility and enrollment system which
manages access to food stamps um cash
assistance and U Medicaid as well as
foster care programming and then our
Nexus system which is our child support
system our Medicaid system for Medicaid
beneficiaries and it goes on there's a
number of different systems each one of
those systems are managed by a vendor in
order to change our practices we would
have to change amend all of those
contracts and change and pull that data
out and make sure that it's expunged and
in its entirety which would cost
millions of dollars across the different
contracted systems and the reason why I
say it's millions of dollars and not a
specific number is we would have to
actually go and engage with them do an
amendment get it approved through
government executive counsel and then
move forward with the initiative to
actually do the work um historically
those amendments are upwards of 800,000
to anywhere in the three to four million
depending on the vendor and so I'm using
it based off a historical knowledge of
those amendments to do this type of work
um I'm certainly open to more discussion
if you have questions I can go into
detail and bore you even more if you
wish and it's up to
thank you madam chair um this data
collection and sharing how has it
shifted from physical record to
electronic medical record that shift is
a huge
shift click of one button can go to
different places versus
world thank you representative that's a
very good question um since the Advent
of technology and electronic health
record systems and that interoperability
and exchange of data in a digital world
it allows for actually even more
stringent controls over the data yes you
can at a click of a button potentially
share it with more people however we
have Protections in place which are
called like data leakage protection so
on our email systems in order to send
data out if you send data out with
social security number or a birth date
or any that type of information it
actually catches that and securely and
encrypts it on purpose and actually
sends you back saying hey you're you're
sending this data to an outside Source
are you sure you want to move it forward
and it presents a secure connection and
we have reports on that so if somebody
sends out data inadvertently to 100
people that would be considered a
security event first and we'd go and we
actually have what we call a security
incident response team that gets gets
enacted and goes and finds out exactly
who that data was shared with and was it
was was it shared with people that were
contracted with the department and are
covered under Hippa and all the other
concerns or if they're not and if
they're not it becomes a reportable
event to both CMS and OCR and other
Federal Regulation or fed regulatory um
organizations and we have a mitigation
plan to say how do we prevent that in
the future it's the same as if if you
had a paper system and someone came in
having forbid and robbed your office and
took all your files you would also be
obligated to do the same exact instant
response at which point you would um
still have to report because the data in
physical form and digital form you still
have to do the same protections so when
I look at this from a perspective of
security and
privacy um I personally would rather my
data in the digital world because I know
that there's keys in multiple doors in
front of that data so in order to get
access to that information it in its
entirety you have to know all those
doors go through data governance
processes follow the right forms get the
data stewards to approve it and move it
forward can a few records be shared
inadvertently yes you have that risk in
a physical or a digital world either
way the only thing that I would add is
just the opportunity sometime you may
want to talk with the division of Vital
Records they've really been um and
probably uh representative boltim is
also to um be credited for this the
digital uh work that we have done in
vital records has really been
extraordinary and long I've worked for
the Department for close to a quarter
Century that has been electronic and New
Hampshire's really led the way in some
of these issues around security of of
data if the committee doesn't have any
other questions do you have any other
we'll move up so um thank you I would
like to invite chawe and Lisa to come up
right now um they're going to talk very
shortly about what we do especially with
some of the health information because I
know that's a concern and then we'll get
to the economics so how do we use this
how do we create health statistics um
and how is that used in the community
and we're going to be very short I'm
going to hand something out to you stack
reports what I will do right now we have
two reports that are just examples of
things that simply would not exist
anymore if we did not have access to
this
data
I'm sorry let me just are these two
separate handouts okay okay thank you
thank
you good afternoon for the records my
name is Jo Chola CH a Hui c h a WLA a
I'm the bureau chief for public health
statistic informatic in the division of
Public Health
Services so I would like to describe and
provide some information how how
statistic performed the uh data analysis
and statistic um work uh regarding vital
record
data so in New Hampshire um RSA 126
24b the Bureau of Health statistic uh
within the Department of Health and
Human Services is
designated the health statistics Center
for New Hampshire in accordance with
public law
95623 Section 5 so the bureau is
authorized to coordinate and destinated
health related information for the
purpose of protecting Public Health
while adhering of uh to privacy
requirement so under the mou the bureau
oh I just want to uh provide another
information based on the uh director
Withers um uh information provided uh
for Vital Records um the data steward is
under the Bureau of Health statistic so
as a bureau chief my role is performed
as a is performing as a data Steward for
the V record data for the
department and with the mou that the
department has with division of Vital
Records under the Secretary of State uh
the bureau also perform Vital Records
data QA which is very important uh part
uh under this agreement that the
department provided the data uh quality
control and Assurance result back to
division of Vital Records so because of
this we have found uh several data
issues um and we report back to division
of Vital Records some example is like
during the inter uh jurisdictional
exchange the out of state records we
received from uh Massachusetts for the
death records uh some of them did not
have ICD code um which is a very key
information for us to understand um the
cause of the death and we work with the
battle record for them to con contact
the massachusett to understand uh you
know if there was any issues in their
system so the the purpose I mentioned
this is uh the department performed this
type of a qway and in order for us to
perform this type of qway we do need to
have identifiers in order to report back
to division of battle records which
records or which records have some
specific issues and the finding that we
found uh during the record um
validation another part that the
identifiers is very important at Le for
the uh Health statistic work is address
um validation so the data quality
provided by V records uh DVR excuse me
is pretty good uh we do found we do find
uh some records that um you know address
is not pared correctly in terms of a
county or public health regions that may
be because uh the record was updated or
maybe because those records are from out
of state uh on New Hampshire residents
that um this type of address is not um
accurate or or coded wrongly some
example is like bad firm New Hampshire
may have Massachusetts ZIP code or bford
Massachusetts may have New Hampshire ZIP
code and the county we also found that
some record has C conquered address on
uh City conquered however the county is
coas County so this type of data qual um
validation and QA work we work very
closely with the division of V records
and uh the bureau also perform us a uh
point of contact to work with the V
record
directly as for the health
statistics the bureau um also produ uh
produce excuse me the DHHS data portal
currently we have more than 50 uh
indicators from both birth and death uh
V records datas and
um I just want to emphasize that uh the
if this bill um in
act that will restrict the department to
receive interjurisdictional data that is
a huge um impact on us so I just want to
provide some information uh regarding
the neighbor State or how we we we we
have um the the out of state data for
the New Hampshire residents so apparent
um averagely 10% of the data in B
recular birth and and that is from out
of state on New Hampshire residence so
uh between 2019 and
2023 um several towns has have
significantly out of state birth and
death so for example PLO uh in between
2019 and
2023 63% of babies were born out of
state so without this data we won't know
63% of um birth records how you know we
won't have the the accit to those birth
records and in Salem similar with plasto
62.9 B is were born out of
state yeah yeah and and that has huge
impacts in terms of our ability to again
to not only the public health the
statistics but also the economic
supports because we simply would not
have that information on a b a Salem
resident who was born across the board
yes um so other than that the bureau
also performed uh data linkage project
um I also sorry before we go to data
linkage project I just want to um also
mention mentioned that under the mou uh
the department um and the division of V
records uh established the V record
privacy board and this board the purpose
of this board is to review all the
confidential data request for Vital
Records data uh all the application and
also the um contined use application
will go to the board uh for review and
approval once the request is approved
then the Department of Health Human
Services will distributed the data based
on the approval uh from the board uh if
we are not able to uh receive all the
identifiers then the department will not
be able to perform this type of work
because all the confidential data
request most of them or all of them
require like a names address and all the
identifiers and of course they all have
IRB approval that's the part that the
board will review and all the
applications and also supplemental
documents will uh provide to the board
for review and approval not all the
studies will be approved they need to
have a very specific study designs and
purpose and good uh study um Logic for
the board to be able to consider and
approve this type of study so the
department also perform this kind of a
um discrimination on This Confidential
data request if the department is not
able to receive all the identifiers uh
and also the house statistic
informations then for this type of work
we won't be able to
perform yeah um before Lisa starts as we
get ready Lisa is going to talk a little
bit about the programmatic I believe
representative McGuire has a question
yes thank you the vital records privacy
board how was that created who I mean
who authorized it uh it's under um sorry
12625 C uh under the um mou that we have
the department has with the division of
V records and the SOS and I and I would
just add that part of the reason why um
DHHS is tasked with that is because we
are the hippoc covered entity not the
Secretary of State's office I was just
wondering was it establish it's a
statute it is in statute thank you it's
a statute and statute also say that
three uh three members will be appointed
by the commissioner of DHHS and three
members will be appointed by the SOS
Secretary of State thank you thank you
great I I was on that board for about
five years Bal records privacy board
thank
you representative rep I got term termed
out and representative Horgan took my
position and I took his position with
Vital Records
Improvement advisory commission thank
you as Lisa um prepares to talk she
talks from the programmatic aspect I
just wanted note again we we gave you
two reports one's on maternal mortality
one is just a report that we're working
that's used right now to um to design
Medicaid services what's our rate
setting and our U Med Medicaid Managed
Care Program those are just
informational but it's exactly the type
of data that chawe was discussing that
we would no we simply would not be able
to perform any of that data analysis
anymore if this bill were to move
forward these have fiscal implications
which I think um Lisa can talk about
because um in general and we were asked
this in the previous committee what does
it mean you'll lose this money well
oftentimes in our federal reports to get
the Federal grant you have to show a
certain level of data you have to say we
have x% of um pre-term births or we have
x% of maternal mortality that's to even
be considered for the funding to
continue the funding we have to show
evaluations did you make a difference
and you have to use this data to make a
difference to uh show that you've made a
difference in order to continue the
funding so it's a bit down the in the
weeds but without it's fundamental if
you don't have the data you don't get
the money so I'm going to hand that over
to Lisa can may I address one more thing
regarding the uh data modernization so
CDC uh recently not recently they have
been pushing data modernization
initiative to provide states fundings to
modernize their data system V record
statistic data system is one of the
modernization however New Hampshire is
the only state that the V statistic uh
system is not on the DHHS so division of
V records cannot receive this data
modernization funding which is um about
$2.7 million uh for two years and
because of DHHS we are able to establish
another number and other mou in order to
um you know receive the funding and
support uh division of V record
Administration for their data
modernization initiative I just want to
emphasize that uh if there's a
um a chance that the DJ just is not able
to receive uh based on our statute uh
direct and and tangable inch to use V
record data this part of funding may be
discontinued
to yeah did you have a question I could
yeah um so you I've seen seen this
report you've talked about my question
is
why do you need the personal identified
information to generate this why
specifically yes whoever can answer yeah
I can talk about the maternal one okay
great pleas um hi good morning uh good
afternoon my name is Lisa sarice I'm a
bureau chief for family health and
nutrition in public health and so my
Bureau works very closely with chia's
Bureau with the data and so I have the
program folks Who oversee newborn
screening so I'll speak to a little bit
about what that work does as well as the
maternal mortality program so they
oversee the committee that does this
work who who have generated that report
so for example in order for our team to
know the details of what maternal deaths
happen in our state we utilize vital
Vital Records to query that information
so that we know what our recent maternal
deaths were in a year in those who were
pregnant so then under statute we have
permission to then do chart abstractions
to learn a little bit more about what
some of the factors were associated with
that death or with that woman and then
we use that data to then allocate
resources program funding to do that
preventative work if I could inter so um
is the issue that if you don't have the
uh pii then you can't connect that to
the Chart or other information okay
thank you the other thing I'll just add
to that is it also makes our overall dat
data incomplete so again just
prematurity rates teen birth rates all
of that because with just uh aggregate
numbers or non-statistical there may be
four things that happen to a particular
individual but that's going to look like
perhaps four individuals that the math
just won't work out correctly at the end
of the day unless you can attach and
again to the security point we have a
very small handful of people who do this
who do that data linkage and then drop
the identifiers once the linkage happens
quick followup if I could y so I
mean I've been involved in some of this
in Private Industry so couldn't you
get um
information I guess the question is
could you get something that wasn't
didn't have pii in it but you could
somehow you know connect that the uh
that these people are together but you
don't know who they are so for some of
our work that could work
so potentially
but then you have things like maternal
mortality where you actually need the
name in order to find that out newborn
screening where you need the name
there's other areas where you absolutely
need the address because we know that
there is a higher teen birth rate in
Coos County than there is in conquered
there are all the pii serves different
function and then ultimately for the
Human Services side of the house you
need to be able to establish um
paternity parentage um address
citizenship and those all require names
I can add on
that sorry if I may yeah sorry so pii is
not just about names we also use date of
birth and also address for date of birth
we calculate um the the mother's age and
the father's age and also we also use
date of death and date of birth to
calculate a disase uh age sometimes this
information is not really derived uh
correctly in the uh V record uh data for
example for newborn or fedal death uh
they recorded as a month so it will be
23 but the column we got is ear so we
will if we don't have the date of birth
and date of death which is part of pii
to do the validation this part This
Record will not be considered as a baby
or newborn death so this a part of a pii
that we we use to calculate age and
other Pi that we use like address not
only to do the uh the address validation
we also use address to do G coding so
the department uh over Public Health use
address to Dr code into sensor track and
sensor block for small area uh data
Outlook if I could I'll just share a
little bit more about some of the
Practical programming that we do when we
utilize the vital records data so
similar to the maternal mortality Review
Committee we have a sudden death in the
youth child fatality Review Committee
which is also under statute and so the
information that is accessed through the
vital records also allows us to know
which child deaths we had for the year
so that we can similarly do chart
abstraction um and it's important to
know when these review committees are
happening that that personal information
is not shared with the group um another
program that we have is our uh newborn
screening programs and so we've heard a
lot about those so there is statute that
requires the hospitals to report to our
newborn screening program however we use
the vital records data to sort of be a
safety net to make sure that no infant
is missed in that process and so a query
is done to make sure that those um blood
spots happen that they come to the
program and those families are followed
up on um in a timely manner and not
missed because we know that it's could
be lifethreatening similarly to the
blood spot we have a hearing detection
program so similarly we use the vital
records for that safety net to make sure
that infants aren't missed for important
screenings that happen in those few days
after life we have the birth conditions
program that we oversee that also we
utilize that pii information and vital
records and then we have a pregnancy
risk assessment U System a survey system
where we pull a sample of women who
recently were pregnant and then we
follow up with a survey to learn a
little bit more about what their
birthing experience was like through
their healthare providers um and so we
use that information to then do program
planning resource allotment so that we
can put preventative and treatment
programs out into the community in the
areas that need them
most I think that's good um and with
your Indulgence we'll we'll try and get
somebody else up here too unless there
question nope I'm going the questions I
just we just have to leave in
like let's say 10 okay so um I will let
the economic supports people decide
amongst themselves who would like to be
representative of the group whether it's
the child care folks or tan or whatever
because I think similarly I think
similarly they all use the information
to do things like establishing parentage
to ensure that economic supports are
available to New Hampshire residents so
up
good afternoon um Madam chair and um
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Lisa decowski D Kut
oi I'm the bureau chief with the Bureau
of Child Support Services so our program
under the department administers the
child support program um of course our
program is a federal state um and tribal
partnership program that was established
by the Social Security Act uh part title
Roman numeral 4D um and naturally our
program seeks to promote economic
stability and as it is already uh stated
one of the primary functions of our
program is to establish legal parentage
and legal paternity specifically legal
fatherhood as well as locating parents
for families and establishing legal Ord
of child support and medical support uh
for our um customers so the Bureau of
Child Support Services um uh as a
federally um you know uh uh invested
program uh certainly has a direct and
tangible interest in accessing the vital
records information for our program to
be able to execute our uh child support
responsibilities um as it has already
stated you know we also follow the same
uh stringent state and federal
safeguarding and confidentiality
requirements um but because one of our
responsibilities of the department is to
establish the legal parentage access to
that vital records information is
actually specified within the federal
law of the Social Security Act of our
part D which I believe had already been
stated in prior testimony um and often
times um there are a variety of areas
that our program um is intertwined with
the work of Vital Records um and so if
we were not to have access to these
personal identifiers um and the
information we would not be able to
execute our program um it would be very
difficult for us to establish child
support for families establish parentage
um and so it would be very difficult for
us to assist and locate um functions
both for the Department department for
locate investigations things of that
nature that we are allowed to do Under
the Social Security Act of the child
support program um and you
know the birth certificate the birth
record is is a one of the most widely
used documents that we use um there and
so it would be essential for us to
continue to be able to have that for our
program to run um you know our program
Services about 30,000 families in the
child uh in New Hampshire currently but
we also service U folks out of state as
well as internationally and tribal
communities um our program brings uh
collects money for families roughly
about $74 million on the last Federal
fiscal year that we've distributed for
collections to families so our work is
really power Mount um but our program is
um our state plan under our state plan
the Department's child support program
is federally funded and we're federally
funded at a rate of 6 6 6% so we are
conditioned on ensuring that we are in
full compliance with all of our federal
requirements to be able to administer
our program and the concern here would
be that um if if we were not allowed to
have the per personal identifiers we
would be at risk of violation of those
um Federal requirements to be able to
perform our duties and there would be
significant loss of federal funding so
we would not be able to um um have a
program here for the child support uh
recipients that we serve in New
Hampshire um I am certainly available to
answer or ask any questions I know we're
under a time straint but um if you have
any specific questions I'd be happy to
answer
them I do have a recommendation to the
subcommittee which consists of
myself um representative Fitzpatrick
representative mipi and representative
Maguire because this is a very
complicated issue and doesn't seem to be
one that is going to go
away I'm I would like to make a Rec
recommendation to the subcommittee that
we recommend to our committee interim
study on this bill that way we can
discuss it in more detail over the
summer and we can address this once and
for all does that make sense with the
subcommittee
I support that yes it makes a great deal
of sense yes because the more we hear
about it the more
pieces pop up that need to be changed
and I don't want to take a meex to a
system that seems to be
working but on the other hand I do want
to continue to implement priv our
privacy protections and but this is not
a
a a simple
issue if nothing else the testimony at
the
first what we we heard before the full
committee was that there's a whole lot
of other rsas that are affected by this
process that would need to be changed
it's not just what's in the bill we'd
have to go through a whole lot of other
areas to make sure we weren't creating
conflicts and I don't think we can do
that in the time available
just for attenders knowledge I'm not on
the subcommittee so I'm not being asked
my opinions but I share the the opinions
that were expressed by my
colleagues so I'll move um interm study
is there a second second okay I'm going
to put Carol and then all those in
favor
okay okay thank thank you very much and
thank you all for
coming we will be talking to many of you
yes while we study this because it we we
get